I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi, you guys.
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。嗨，你们好。
All right. Today we're talking about business trip. At first. We have a fantastic interview for you. Yes. We are going to be talking with Rich Summer. Who played Alex? Art school Alex.
好的。今天我们来聊聊“商务出差”。首先。我们为你准备了一场精彩的采访。是的。我们将与里奇·萨默对话。饰演亚历克斯的那位。艺术学院的亚历克斯。
I know. We love Rich. We're good friends with Rich in real life. Yes. My stepson and Rich's daughter B are in a book club. You guys, they meet every week. It's the cutest thing. It's the cutest thing.
我知道。我们很喜欢里奇。我们在现实生活中和里奇是好朋友。是的。我继子和里奇的女儿B在一个读书俱乐部里。伙计们，他们每周都见面。这太可爱了。这太可爱了。
You might know Rich Summer because he played Harry Crane on all seven seasons of Mad Men. And at that same time, he was doing his arc on The Office as Pam's art school friend. Friend? Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Question mark. And Jenna and Rich spent a ton of time together filming all those scenes and became really good friends.
你可能认识里奇·萨默，因为他在《广告狂人》的所有七季中饰演了哈里·克兰。与此同时，他还在《办公室》中客串了帕姆在艺术学院的朋友。朋友？嗯哼。嗯哼。问号。詹娜和里奇花了很多时间一起拍摄所有这些场景，并成为了非常要好的朋友。
We did. We just had to talk to him. We wanted to hear his side of the story of filming that crazy scene with the little Bluetooth earpieces from customer survey. We talked about it last week with Steven Merchant. Yeah, we needed Rich's take on that. We really did. And we talked all things The Office for Alex.
我们确实如此。我们只是必须和他谈谈。我们想听听他讲述拍摄《客户调查》中那个戴着小小蓝牙耳机的疯狂场景的故事。我们上周和斯蒂芬·莫昌特聊过这个。是的，我们需要里奇对这件事的看法。我们真的需要。而且我们和亚历克斯聊了关于《办公室》的一切。
And here is that interview. Rich Summer, welcome to Office Ladies. Hi, Rich. Thank you. Hi, Angela and Jenna. Oh my gosh, when we post the photo from this interview, Rich looks so professional. Mm-hmm. I can't believe you're saying that.
以下就是那段采访。里奇·萨默，欢迎来到“办公室女士”。嗨，里奇。谢谢。嗨，安吉拉和詹娜。哦天哪，当我们发布这次采访的照片时，里奇看起来太专业了。嗯哼。我简直不敢相信你在这么说。
I am in a teeny, tiny box. I just have a wide-angle camera. It makes it look cool. I know, but you have the stuff that looks like egg carton. You know what I mean? You have the real deal sound stuff. That's $10 at a foam place in Burbank that I went to. Jenna, should we have done that?
我呆在一个极小极小的盒子里。我只有一个广角镜头。这让它看起来很酷。我知道，但你有看起来像鸡蛋纸盒的东西。你知道我的意思吗？你有真正专业的录音设备。那是花10美元在伯班克的一家泡沫店买的，我去的。詹娜，我们本该那样做吗？
Across from the old Toys R Us. We probably should have gone there. Maybe we should have gone there. Well, you text us about it later when we get done. Yes, I will. I also want to share that as we were setting up this Zoom, my microphone broke, so I'm using a backup microphone, so I probably sound the worst of all of us. Rich is going to sound the best.
就在老玩具反斗城对面。我们当时大概应该去那里的。也许我们本该去那里的。好吧，等我们录完后你发短信告诉我们。好的，我会的。我还想分享的是，当我们正在设置这个Zoom时，我的麦克风坏了，所以我用的是备用麦克风，所以我的声音听起来可能是我们所有中最差的。里奇的声音听起来会是最好的。
You look the most professional. Mm-hmm. Rich is what matters. You're what matters, Rich. We're here for you. Sure. We're excited to talk to you. We are.
你看起来最专业。嗯哼。里奇才是最重要的。你才是最重要的，里奇。我们为你来到这里。当然。我们很高兴能和你聊天。我们是的。
Rich, we always ask everyone on the show how they got their job on the office. Did you audition for the part? Do you have a story? We have heard that Mindy was lobbying very hard for you. Did you know Mindy? To my recollection, Mindy and I met at the SAG Awards when you guys and the Mad Men cast were nominated, and Mindy was a fan of Mad Men and came up to me, and I was so excited to meet her.
里奇，我们总是问节目中的每个人他们是如何得到《办公室》的工作的。你去试镜这个角色了吗？你有什么故事吗？我们听说敏迪曾为你大力游说。你认识敏迪吗？据我回忆，我和敏迪是在演员工会奖上认识的，当时你们和《广告狂人》的剧组都获得了提名，敏迪是《广告狂人》的粉丝，她向我走来，我当时能见到她超级兴奋。
We had chatted maybe a couple of times, but she came up to me and said, hey, I'm writing a part with you in mind on the show. Would that be okay if I— Oh, my gosh. I said, well, I was like, yes, because, you know, like everybody else, the office was one of my favorite shows on TV, so it was a really exciting thing to have, you know, an actor, writer, producer from another show, any show say that to you, but to have it be one of your favorite shows that you are so excited to even step into that world.
我们可能聊过一两次，但她走过来对我说，嘿，我在剧里为你量身打造了一个角色。如果你觉得可以的话——哦，天哪。我说，嗯，我当时想，好啊，因为你知道，就像其他人一样，办公室是我电视上最喜欢的节目之一，所以能有一个来自另一个节目的演员、编剧、制片人，不管是什么节目，对你这么说，这是一件非常令人兴奋的事情，但更不用说它还是你最喜欢的节目之一，能让你甚至有机会踏入那个世界。
It was incredibly special. Yes. That is so cool. So, is that what happened? They just offered you the role after she had written it? Yeah, they reached out and offered it. And I had a friend of mine who I hadn't told him yet about that, and he said, oh, I just auditioned for the office, and I was like, oh, that's awesome.
这真是太特别了。是的。太酷了。所以，事情就是这样吗？她在写完这个角色后直接把这个角色交给了你？是的，他们联系了我并提供了这个角色。我有一个朋友，我当时还没把这事告诉他，他说，哦，我刚刚去《办公室》试镜了，然后我说，哦，那太棒了。
I'm hoping to audition for them as well. And he said, yes, for this part, I guess Pam goes to art school and she's going to meet some guy at art school, and I was like, uh-huh, oh, good, good, good. And in my head, I knew what Mindy had said, and we hadn't finalized anything yet, and you know how these things work in the business. They'll keep auditioning, even if they have an offer out to someone or in conversation with someone, they'll keep auditioning other people. I'm usually on the auditioning end of that, where I'm throwing an audition down a hole
我也希望能去他们那里试镜。然后他说，是的，为了这个角色，我猜帕姆去上艺术学校了，她将在艺术学校遇到某个人，然后我就想，嗯哼，哦，很好，很好，很好。在我的脑海里，我知道敏迪说过的话，我们当时还没最终敲定任何事情，而且你知道这种事情在业内是如何运作的。他们会继续试镜其他人，即使他们已经向某人发出了邀约或者正在和某人沟通，他们也会继续试镜其他人。我通常是处于试镜的那一端，把试镜机会扔进一个洞里
rather than, you know, being the one that's actually being considered. But this was one of those rare times. So as soon as the offer came through officially, I was, I accepted immediately. But yes, it was, I did audition for the office a time or two with Alice and Jones. But I didn't get those roles, and then this came through, and it was just an offer. Well, Rich, you mentioned that you met Mindy at a SAG Awards party. Something people should know, I guess, is just that the cast of the office and the cast of Mad Men, we kind of glommed onto each other.
而不是（你知道的）真正被考虑的那个人。但这可以说是罕见的几次例外之一。所以一旦官方邀约通过，我就立刻接受了。不过是的，我确实和爱丽丝·琼斯一起为《办公室》试镜过一两次。但我没有得到那些角色，然后这个机会就来了，它直接就是个邀约。好吧，里奇，你提到你是在一次演员工会奖派对上认识敏迪的。人们应该知道的一点是，《办公室》的演员阵容和《广告狂人》的演员阵容，我们有点粘在一起了。
We were on the rise at the same time, and we were kind of experiencing the same thing of being both casts that were basically unknown actors suddenly on these really popular shows. And so we would go around to all of these events together, and we all became really good friends. It was a really sort of spectacular odd marriage between the shows, because we ended up, like you say, our groups. Because the way the SAG Awards work, in particular, is the entire cast of each show is seated together at one or two tables, depending on the size of the group.
我们当时正处于上升期，而且我们经历着类似的事情——两部剧的演员基本上都是不知名的演员，突然间就出演了这些非常受欢迎的节目。所以我们会一起参加所有这些活动，我们都成为了非常好的朋友。这些节目之间有一种非常奇妙古怪的联结，因为我们最后，就像你说的，我们的群体。因为演员工会奖的运作方式，特别是，每个节目的整个演员阵容都根据团体的大小坐在一两张桌子旁。
And then at the party, there's usually like, there's this corner for Mad Men and this area for the office, and every show sort of has an area. And our areas often ended up being near each other and at least ended up being sort of shared real estate. It was a very, it was a very cool relationship between the groups. Yeah, some of my favorite memories from that time are our casts hanging together. It was really cool. I remember people watching at the Mad Men party.
然后在派对上，通常会有一个《广告狂人》的角落和《办公室》的区域，每个节目都有一个区域。而我们的区域经常最终挨得很近，或者至少最终变成了某种共享的现实地产。这些群体之间有一种非常酷、非常棒的关系。是的，我那段时间最喜欢的记忆之一就是我们的演员们聚在一起。真的很酷。我记得在《广告狂人》的派对上观察人们。
There was a Mad Men after party, and Oscar Nunez and I sat on a couch, and we were side barring as everyone walked by. We were like, look at this guy. Check that guy out. Those Mad Men after parties sometimes, I mean, every show has sort of the people that you are always like, I can't believe they watch our show. And I know you guys had that too. It was very strange times.
有一个《广告狂人》的after-party，奥斯卡·努涅斯和我坐在一张沙发上，当每个人走过时，我们在旁边发表着旁白。我们当时想，看那个家伙。瞧瞧那个家伙。那些《广告狂人》的after-party有时，我是说，每个节目都有那种让你总是觉得“我简直不敢相信他们看我们的节目”的人。我知道你们也有过这种感觉。那是非常奇怪的时期。
I'm curious, what were you told about the role of Alex before you came in? Did you get anything to read? And were you told specifically that you were an art school friend or you were a possible love interest? How was this role pitched to you? Well, this is going to be, this is the meaty part of the conversation, I suppose. The way it was pitched to me, this was the beginning of season five, obviously, and the way it was pitched to me was that it would be a, now I should also clarify, especially
我很好奇，在你来之前，关于亚历克斯这个角色，你被告知了什么？你有没有拿到什么剧本去读？是否具体告诉你你是一个艺术学校的朋友，还是你是一个潜在的恋爱对象？这个角色是怎么向你推销的？嗯，这将会是，这将会是谈话中有分量的一部分，我想。向我推销的方式是，这是第五季的开始，显然，向我推销的方式是它将是一个，现在我也应该澄清，特别是
if Mindy is listening, I'm not saying that Mindy pitched me anything. It was conversational. It was just sort of like we think this is a character who's going to be throughout this season. We think it's a character that's going to be kind of like Rashida's character was where it might be a little bit of another road bump for Jim and Pam. So when it started, that was definitely what was in my mind. But we filmed scenes that didn't make it into the show and I started to kind of put together
如果敏迪在听的话，我不是说敏迪向我推销了什么。这只是一种对话式的。这有点像我们认为这是一个将贯穿本季的角色。我们认为这个角色将会有点像拉什达的角色那样，可能会成为吉姆和帕姆之间的一点小小的路障。所以当它开始时，这绝对是我脑海中的想法。但我们拍摄了一些没有进入正片的场景，我开始有点拼凑出
that the response from the audience were so, because your show, how long in advance did you guys shoot and then air? I would say only three to four weeks, maybe. There was a pretty tight turnaround. It felt really tight. Yeah. Yeah. It was enough time, or a short enough time, I should say, that the audience response to
来自观众的反应是如此，因为你们的节目，你们从拍摄到播出提前了多久？我会说只有三到四周，也许吧。周转周期相当紧凑。感觉真的很紧。是的。是的。时间足够长，或者说时间足够短，我应该说，观众的反应
my first appearance was, had landed before I was filming customer survey and they were not pleased. They were not pleased. They did not want to see Pam like with anyone, but Jim, oh man. No, and who could blame them after what they had been through for four seasons, who could blame them? I know. Well, you have very kind of flirty eyes in your first scenes at art school.
在我第一次出场时就已经传到了，当时我正在拍摄《客户调查》，而他们很不高兴。他们很不高兴。他们不想看到帕姆和除吉姆之外的任何人在一起，天哪。不，经历了四个赛季的那些风雨之后，谁又能怪他们呢？谁又能怪他们呢？我知道。好吧，你在艺术学校的第一场戏里有着非常含情脉脉的眼神。
You're very flirty and you're right. Those scenes aired and all of a sudden, Tiki Bar is on the cutting room floor, right? There is a whole Alex storyline with Pam, actually the whole Pam art storyline, is in deleted scenes. I watched the deleted scenes for the podcast and every week I'm like, Jenna, oh my gosh, there's this scene and this scene and one in the hallway and at a bar and here and she's like, I know. How did it feel to watch those scenes get cut week to week?
你非常调情，你说得对。那些场景播出了，突然之间，提基酒吧就留在了剪辑室的地上，对吧？实际上，关于帕姆和亚历克斯有一整条故事线，整个帕姆艺术故事线都在被删减片段里。我为了播客看了被删减的片段，每周我都想，詹娜，哦天哪，这里有个场景，那里有个场景，走廊里有一个，酒吧里有一个，这里还有一个，然后她就说，我知道。看着这些场景一周又一周地被剪掉，是什么感觉？
Did anyone warn you? As far as how it felt, look. I am very, I consider myself fortunate that I have a fairly, I don't know, comfortable ability to see where things fit in story-wise and I could feel from the moment we were, the second anybody said, this feels weird. This is too much consternation for Jim and Pam. I agreed. I mean, again, I was a fan from the beginning.
有人警告过你吗？至于感觉如何，你看。我非常，我认为自己很幸运，我拥有相当——我不知道——舒适的能力，能看出事物在故事中的契合点，从我们身处其中的那一刻起，当任何人说，这感觉很奇怪。这对吉姆和帕姆来说太令人焦虑了。我是赞同的。我的意思是，再说一次，我从一开始就是个粉丝。
Now, I would have loved to have gotten to be around more, but I also wasn't going to be greedy. I remain delighted that I had the parts that I had. I do think it's a funny part of Office Lore because it seems clear to me at least that this was a sort of aborted storyline that they kind of cut bait when they could. And that was, I don't know, I just think it's, how I feel about it is that it's a very funny interesting way to have been a part of the Office legacy. Well, I was bummed that you never came to the actual set because we never got to hang
现在，我本很希望能有更多机会出现，但我也不会贪心。我依然很高兴我拥有过我所饰演的角色。我确实认为这是《办公室》传说中一个有趣的部分，因为它对我来说至少很清楚，这是一个某种程度上被中止的故事线，他们在可以的时候及时止损了。那是，我不知道，我只是觉得，我对它的感受是，成为《办公室》传奇的一部分是一种非常有趣、非常酷的方式。好吧，我很难过你从来没有真正去过片场，因为我们从来没有机会在片场一起玩
out on set and you and Jenna would have stories and we were missing Jenna. You know, Jenna was who I had lunch with every day and I was like, gosh, why can't Alex just, you know, show up with Pam at work one day? Of course, that would have completely blown up the storyline, but we were sad you were never in the actual bullpen. Should we talk about this insane scene that we filmed for customer survey with Steven Merchant? First of all, did you crap your pants when you found out Steven Merchant was directing?
而你和詹娜会有故事，而我们很想念詹娜。你知道的，詹娜是我每天一起吃午饭的人，我当时想，天哪，为什么亚历克斯就不能（你知道的）某天和帕姆一起出现在工作单位呢？当然，那会彻底炸毁整个故事线，但你从来不在真正的办公区，我们为此感到难过。我们是不是应该聊聊我们在《客户调查》中为斯蒂芬·莫昌特拍摄的那个疯狂的场景？首先，当你发现斯蒂芬·莫昌特要来导演时，你有没有吓得屁滚尿流？
Because I did. I did poop myself. Yep. Yep. Yes. Yeah, it was upsetting. 10% exciting, 90% okay. I had no idea, Rich, how many different ways you guys did this scene.
因为我真的拉裤子了。没错。没错。是的。对，那挺让人沮丧的。10%的兴奋，90%的还好。里奇，我完全不知道你们拍这场戏竟然有那么多不同的方式。
You know, we got the scripts and all the alts from James Carey and I could not believe it. Jenna told me how many different versions were there, Jenna? I think there was something like 10. Good night. Now I wasn't privy to all of those versions because as a guest actor, I was really only given the script on the day. This is how I remember it and I've listened to you guys talk about it with Steven and my memory is slightly different, but I don't know where it goes off.
你知道的，我们收到了詹姆士·凯瑞写的剧本和所有备选台词，我简直不敢相信。珍娜告诉我当时有多少种不同的版本，珍娜？我想大概有10种左右吧。晚安。现在，我并不是所有版本都知道，因为作为一个客串演员，我基本上只有在当天才能拿到剧本。我是这样记忆的，而且我听过你们和史蒂文讨论过这个，我的记忆稍微有些不同，但我不知道是从哪个地方开始有偏差的。
I've certainly mulled over this aspect of the story a thousand times, so it's probably gotten altered as I've gone, but here was my problem. My problem was that I had a mull on the inside and I don't know if I've ever even told you guys about this and I won't name the person on the podcast. You had a mull on the set of the office? I won't name this person on the podcast, but this was a person who was not an actor who worked in the production and this person sent me the script early. He said, oh, you've got some great stuff in this coming episode.
我肯定把故事的这个方面在脑海里琢磨过上千次了，所以随着时间推移它可能变味了，但我的问题在于：我的问题是我在内部出了点岔子——我不知道我有没有跟你们说过这个，我也不会在播客里说出这个人的名字。你在《办公室》剧组里出了岔子？我不会在播客里说出这个人的名字，但这个人不是演员，而是负责制作工作的，这个人提前把剧本发给了我。他说，哦，你接下来的这集里有些很棒的戏份。
It's a guy. Oh my God, I'd loved a sh**. Yeah, okay, fine. Yes, it's a guy. So this person sent me the script and I was in that version, Alex professed his love to Pam and I thought, oh, wow, and as it left it open, is this a send-off for my character or is this something that we may see him later on? I showed up on the day I was handed the sides and those sides were, as you guys know, wildly
是个男的。哦天哪，我喜欢胡扯。好吧，好吧，是的，是个男的。所以这个人把剧本发给我了，在那个版本里，亚历克斯向帕姆表白了，我想，哦，哇，而且这个结尾留白了，这是对我的角色的告别演出，还是说我们以后还能看到他？我到了现场，被交给了分镜头台词，而你们也知道，那些台词简直是……
different. They had taken out any profession of love at all, made it purely about her sort of artistic sensibilities and changed how that was going to go. So when we were filming, I will admit this is a fault of mine as an actor. I couldn't get it out of my head because, again, everything we had been playing so far was that Alex had a crush on Pam. And like you guys said with Steven, what Alex ends up saying is enough. It didn't need to be this on-the-nose sort of profession of love.
天差地别。他们完全删掉了任何表白的内容，让整段戏纯粹围绕着她的一些艺术敏感度展开，并且改变了戏的发展方向。所以当我们在拍摄时，我得承认这是我作为演员的一个缺点。我就是无法把它从脑海中挥之不去，因为再次强调，我们之前一直在演的是亚历克斯对帕姆有迷恋。就像你们和史蒂文说的那样，亚历克斯最后说的话其实已经足够了。它不需要那种直白的表白。
It's implied, it's intrinsic. Because Jim says, this guy's into you, it's clearly there, but in the moment, I couldn't find the right level of demonstrative that Steven wanted and the level that Steven wanted was zero. The level that I was continually pumping out was more in the neighborhood of 75% demonstrative. I couldn't reel it in and in fact, Jenna, to your question of pooping my pants when I found out it was Steven Merchant, that was just a little jitter compared to how I felt when Steven came up to me after a take and said these words, the words that have haunted
它是含蓄的，是内在的。因为吉姆说过，这家伙对你有意思，这很明显，但在那一刻，我找不到史蒂文想要的表现力的那个度，而史蒂文想要的度是零。我不断泵送出来的度大约在75%的表现力左右。我无法收敛它，事实上，珍娜，关于当我发现是史蒂文·莫昌特时我是怎么吓得拉裤子的那个问题，比起史蒂文在一个镜头拍完后走过来对我说的那句话，那简直只是个小小的惊吓，正是那句话一直困扰着
me as an actor forever. He came up to me and said, I don't know why you're not getting this. He was, by the way, 100% right, I just couldn't do it. So you know, looking at Jenna Fisher standing across from me, John Krasinski is crumpled up into a ball under the table in that room reading his lines for the Bluetooth. He was there, John was there. I remember he was there, but I didn't remember he was hiding under the table. Oh my God, through all the takes?
我作为一个演员的一生。他走过来对我说，我不知道你为什么就是搞不懂。顺便说一句，他百分之百是对的，我就是做不到。所以你知道的，看着珍娜·费舍尔站在我面前，约翰·克拉辛斯基在这个房间的桌子底下蜷缩成一团，正在读他扮演蓝牙耳机的台词。他在那里，约翰就在那里。我记得他在那儿，但我根本不记得他躲在桌子底下。哦天哪，所有镜头都是这样吗？
There was nowhere for him to hide in the room because it was a small conference room and the cameras, as you guys know, were moving all the time. Everywhere. There was no safe space. So he just hid under the desk. Six foot three, John Krasinski was curled up under the desk. Yes. And I'm just mortified.
房间里根本没有地方让他藏身，因为那是一个很小的会议室，而且如你们所知，摄像机一直在移动。到处都是。没有安全空间。所以他只好躲在桌子底下。身高六尺三寸的约翰·克拉辛斯基就蜷缩在桌子底下。是的。而我简直羞愧难当。
Well, this is it. I'm never acting again, obviously, because Steven Merchant's never going to cast me in anything. Well, Jenna and John think I'm absolutely out of my mind. It was a stressful day. It's all great now, but it was a stressful day. Oh my gosh, Rich, I think you're being too hard on yourself and taking on too much of the responsibility because I was also told that Alex might be a possible love interest
好吧，就是这样。我显然再也不会演戏了，因为史蒂文·莫昌特再也不会找我演任何东西了。好吧，珍娜和约翰觉得我简直疯了。那真是压力山大的一天。现在一切都过去挺好了，但那确实是压力巨大的一天。噢天哪，里奇，我觉得你对自己太苛刻了，把太多的责任揽在自己身上，因为我也听说亚历克斯可能是个潜在的恋爱对象
for Pam, not that Pam would have feelings for Alex, but that she might have to manage his feelings for her. And by the way, I want to say I only respected Rich in that moment and so much so that we went on to do a movie together. We did The Giant Mechanical Man. You played my brother-in-law and you were so funny. That's right. The Giant Mechanical Man is a great movie, by the way.
为了帕姆，倒不是说帕姆会对亚历克斯有感觉，而是她可能得应对他对她的感情。顺便说一句，我想说我在那一刻极其尊重里奇，以至于我们后来还一起合作了一部电影。我们拍了《巨型机械人》。你演我大舅子，你太搞笑了。没错。《巨型机械人》顺便说一句是一部很棒的电影。
Great. And you guys are fantastic in it. It's a re... I love that movie. And believe me, in the month or so following my final day at the office, and we had exchanged information because it was clear we were going to be friends. My recollection is when you and Lee reached out to ask if I would come and do a table read for this movie that you guys were working on, it was both so exciting, but also such
太棒了。而且你们在里面演得太精彩了。这是一部……我太喜欢那部电影了。相信我，在我离开《办公室》的最后一天的前后大概一个月里，我们交换了联系方式，因为很显然我们会成为朋友。我的记忆是，当您和李联系我，问我是否愿意来为你们正在制作的这部电影进行一次剧本围读时，这既让人兴奋，又是...
a relief that you had not written me off after that day because it was just such a stressful... You know, you've had those days on a set where you feel like this is my last day on a set. I'm never acting again. Obviously, I am garbage. I don't know why I did this. And usually I don't leave a day feeling that way.
一种解脱，因为在经历了那一天之后，你们并没有把我写进黑名单，因为那实在太令人压力山大了……你知道的，你在片场经历过那种日子，你会觉得这是我在片场的最后一天了。我再也不演戏了。显然，我就是个废物。我不知道我为什么要干这个。通常我离开片场时不会有这种感觉。
It's usually somewhere closer to the middle. But that day I left and I was just like, oh, that is that. That was that. And I hope Mad Men goes forever because this door has been closed. So it was such a relief to have you reach out to the movie. No one felt like that. Everybody thought that you crushed it, really and truly. I thought, I was rooting for Alex and I know I wasn't rooting.
通常感觉会更接近中间状态。但那天我离开时，我就觉得，哦，那就是这样了。事情就是这样了。我希望《广告狂人》永远播下去，因为这扇门已经关上了。所以能接到你们邀请我参与电影的电话，真是一种解脱。没有人那么想。每个人都觉得你演得棒极了，真的。我当时想，我是亚历克斯的支持者，我知道我不是支持...
What? No, listen, listen now so I don't get hate mail. I wasn't rooting for Jim and Pam to break up, but I became like, I thought Alex was so endearing that I just, I want Alex to have a good life. I became that person. Like, I hope Alex finds his person because he's so sweet and kind and I don't know. Rich, I have to ask, how did the set of the office and the way we shot and the way things worked differ from the way you guys made Mad Men?
什么？不，听着，现在听着，免得我收到黑粉信件。我不是在支持吉姆和帕姆分手，但我变得像……我觉得亚历克斯太可爱了，以至于我只想让亚历克斯过上好生活。我成了那种人。就像，我希望亚历克斯能找到属于他的人，因为他太甜美善良了，我不知道。里奇，我得问问，片场的《办公室》以及我们的拍摄方式和运作方式，跟你们拍《广告狂人》的方式有什么不同？
I mean, the ways we are similar is a very short list. The Mad Men set, the filming style was entirely different. First off, for the first three, maybe four seasons of Mad Men, we were still shooting on film. So at this time, when I was doing the office, we were definitely shooting on film. And that, for anyone who's been on a set where they're filming with film, it's a whole other process. It adds a remarkable amount of time.
我的意思是，我们相似的地方列出来是一张非常短的清单。《广告狂人》的剧组，拍摄风格完全不同。首先，在《广告狂人》的前三季，也许是前四季，我们仍然是在用胶片拍摄。所以在这个时候，当我拍《办公室》时，我们绝对是在用胶片拍摄。而且对于任何去过用胶片拍摄的片场的人来说，那是完全不同的一个流程。它增加了相当可观的时间。
And you're even just changing a film mag, you know, the cartridge of film, it has to be sort of taken to a dark place and dealt with so that it can be sent off for processing. And it, the turnarounds on scenes, you know, moving the camera around takes, I don't know, not twice as long, but a lot longer. So the fact that on the office, they would hit roll and almost never stop until they were out of tape, as I recall, right? I mean, it just, it felt like we were always rolling. Yes.
甚至只是换一个胶片暗盒，你知道的，那个胶片盒必须被带到一个黑暗的地方处理，以便送去冲洗。而且，场景的转换，你知道的，移动摄像机需要花费，我不知道，虽然不是两倍长，但要长得多。所以，在《办公室》里，他们会喊开拍，而且几乎从不停止，直到用完磁带，据我回忆，对吧？我的意思是，感觉我们好像一直在拍摄。是的。
It did feel that way, yeah. You could kind of stop mid-scene if you needed to and adjust something, whereas on Mad Men, it was more, if we're filming, everything has to be in order. And if we're, if we cut, then everybody can breathe again. It was just a very different type of precision that they were doing on Mad Men because it was, obviously, the look is not handheld. The look on Mad Men was very carefully and intentionally composed. Not that shots weren't composed on the office, but it was just composed in a different way.
确实有那种感觉，是的。如果需要的话，你可以在场景中途停下来调整一些东西，而在《广告狂人》中，更多的情况是，如果我们正在拍摄，一切都必须井井有条。如果我们喊停，那么所有人才能重新喘口气。《广告狂人》采用的精度是一种非常不同的类型，因为很显然，它的视觉风格不是手持摄像机的风格。在《广告狂人》中，画面是经过非常小心和刻意构图的。并不是说《办公室》里的镜头没有构图，但它的构图方式完全不同。
It was much more fluid. We're watching the show now with our daughter, she's 13 and she's never seen it, and we're probably three quarters of the way through season two. Now she knows, just because it's in the zeitgeist, that Pam and Jim end up together. It is driving her bananas. And I haven't even thought to say, if you think this is tough, wait till Rashida Jones shows up, because she's just frustrated that Roy set a date for the wedding and Jim was sad and Bea was like, this is terrible.
它流畅得多。我们现在正和女儿一起看这部剧，她13岁了，从没看过，我们大概看到了第二季的三分之二。现在她知道了，仅仅因为这是个时代风潮，帕姆和吉姆最后在一起了。这快把她逼疯了。我甚至还没来得及说，如果你觉得这很难受，等罗希达·琼斯出现的时候再说吧，因为她现在就很沮丧，因为罗伊定下了婚礼日期，而吉姆很难过，碧安卡就说，这太糟糕了。
When do they get together? I can't stand it. Like buckle in. I got news for you. It's going to be a minute. Yeah. Rich, she's going to hate you when she gets to your part. Oh yeah.
他们什么时候才能在一起？我受不了了。就像系好安全带一样。我有个消息要告诉你。还要好一会儿呢。是的。里奇，等她看到你出场的那部分时，她会恨死你的。噢，是的。
Oh yeah. She's going to be like at your house. Well, she has been with me when I have been recognized from the office. Oh yeah. We were going to ask, do you get recognized as Alex? I do. And it is amazing to me how often, because sometimes, you know, as actors, we get different people recognize us from different things.
噢，是的。她甚至会去你家。好吧，当我在外面因为《办公室》而被认出来时，她一直和我在一起。噢，是的。我们本来想问，你经常被认出是亚历克斯吗？我确实会。而且这让我惊奇的频率有多高，因为有时，你知道的，作为演员，不同的人会从不同的作品中认出我们。
And truly, it's got to be half the time. It's the office. I mean, I'm on screen for two episodes of the office, so its reach was just sort of astounding to me. But I did. My favorite one is when Beatrice was a baby. I don't even think was a year old. We went to visit my family in Ohio, and we were getting on a connecting flight in Cincinnati.
说实话，大概有一半的时候都是因为《办公室》。我的意思是，我在《办公室》里只出场了两集，所以它的影响力对大卫来说简直让我有些震惊。但我确实遇到了。我最喜欢的一次是碧安卡还是个婴儿的时候。我甚至觉得她还不到一岁。我们去俄亥俄州探望我的家人，我们在辛辛那提转机。
I'm walking my tiny, beautiful little baby girl down the aisle, and this guy leans into the aisle, and he goes, hey, hey, and I sort of start and look, I'm like, yeah. This stranger says, don't f with Pam and Jim. And he meant it, by the way. So I think people, it was in those kinds of moments where I went, oh yeah, yeah, yeah. This is, it's better that Alex goes quietly to the night and they go back to their thing so that I don't, you know, get kidnapped or anything. Oh, Rich, well, you know, maybe Alex had to go away, but we're glad you got to stay in
我推着我那娇小可爱的小女儿走在过道里，这个家伙把身子探进过道，喊道：“嘿，嘿，”我吓了一跳，看着他，心想：“啥？”这个陌生人说：“别他妈惹帕姆和吉姆。”顺便说一句，他是认真的。所以我想人们，就是在那种时刻，我心想，哦，是的，是的，是的。这，最好还是让亚历克斯悄悄消失在夜色中，让他们回到他们的事情上去，这样我就不会，你知道的，被绑架什么的。噢，里奇，好吧，你知道的，也许亚历克斯不得不离开，但我们很高兴你能留在
our lives. Yes. And Rich, thank you so much for coming on the podcast today. It was so great to see you. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you so much for letting me be a part of this. Oh my gosh.
我们的生活中。是的。而且里奇，非常感谢你今天来到播客。很高兴见到你。好的。谢谢。非常感谢让我成为其中的一部分。哦天哪。
I'm just, I'm excited that we got to have you on the show. I'm excited we got to take that trip down memory lane. Hopefully this has been healing. I hope it's been healing. Yes, yes, I promise. I hope it has. Thank you so much, Rich. We love you.
我只是，很高兴能请你来节目。我很高兴我们能一起回顾过去的时光。希望这次经历是有治愈效果的。我希望它是有治愈效果的。是的，是的，我保证。我希望是的。非常感谢你，里奇。我们爱你。
Love you, Rich. Thank you. Love you too. And thanks again for having me. That was so great. Thank you so much, Rich Summer. And now, Jenna, it's time to break down business trip. Mm-hmm.
爱你，里奇。谢谢。我也爱你。再次感谢邀请我。太棒了。非常感谢里奇·萨莫尔。好了，珍娜，现在是时候剖析“出差”这一集了。嗯哼。
It is season five, episode eight. Listen to this dream team written by Brent Forrester and directed by Randall Einhorn. Office ladies, folks, are you ready to go to the international business trip to Kanada? Kanada. Kanada. It's time to go get your passport. International traveler. Yes.
这是第五季第八集。请收听由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧、兰德尔·恩霍恩导演的梦幻团队制作。办公室女士们，各位，你们准备好去加拿大进行国际商务旅行了吗？加拿大。加拿大。是时候去拿你的护照了。国际旅行者。是的。
Let me give you a summary. Please. Michael is ecstatic when David Wallace sends him on an international business trip to Winnipeg, Kanada. Mm-hmm. He brings Oscar and Andy along. While on the trip, Michael romances the concierge and Oscar and Andy bond. Meanwhile, Jim and the rest of the office count down the days until Pam's return, only
我来给你们做个总结。好的。迈克尔听到大卫·华莱士派他去加拿大温尼伯进行国际商务旅行时，欣喜若狂。嗯哼。他带上了奥斯卡和安迪。在旅行期间，迈克尔与礼宾部人员发生了一段浪漫，奥斯卡和安迪增进了感情。与此同时，吉姆和办公室里的其他人都在倒计时数着帕姆回来的日子，结果
to be disappointed when she has to stay in New York for another 12 weeks to retake a course that she failed. Also, Kelly and Ryan get back together. Yes, they do. The deleted scenes on this one are delicious. I'll be sharing some of those. Fast fact number one, we have an awesome guest star alert. Yes, we do.
却感到失望，因为她必须在纽约多呆12周，以便重修她挂科的一门课程。此外，凯利和瑞恩复合了。是的，他们复合了。这一集的删减片段太精彩了。我会分享一些。第一条趣味事实，我们有一个超级棒的客串明星警报。是的，我们有。
It is Wendy McClendon Covey as Concierge Marie. Concierge Marie. How do I love these? She was perfection. You guys might know Wendy. She is the star of the TV show, The Goldbergs. Yes, she plays Beverly. She was in Bridesmaid, So Funny, Reno 911.
她就是温迪·麦克伦敦-考威，饰演礼宾玛丽。礼宾玛丽。我怎么能不爱这些呢？她简直完美。大家可能认识温迪。她是电视剧《戈德堡一家》的主演。是的，她饰演贝弗莉。她演过《伴娘》里非常搞笑的角色，还有《雷诺911》。
She is a member of the Groundlings Improv, and she's just an all-around amazing human being. She is, and she was so delightful. We slid into her DMs. We did. And I was like, Wendy, we have some questions. She was like, of course, and she sent us fantastic audio clips. Of course we had to ask her how she got her role in the office.
她是“格罗夫林斯”即兴剧团的成员，而且她是一个全面开花的令人惊叹的人。她是，而且她太讨人喜欢了。我们悄悄溜进了她的私信。我们确实去了。我说，温迪，我们有一些问题。她说，当然可以，然后她给我们发了超级棒的音频片段。我们当然得问她是如何得到《办公室》里的角色的。
I was not expecting this response. I know me either. Hello, Jenna and Angela, office ladies, gorgeous office ladies. So my audition process, actually, I did not have to audition for the office, but it came to me in an interesting way. First of all, I had been in Michigan for not even 24 hours before I had been fired off of a movie because one of the money guys thought I was too ugly. So my ugly ass was put on a plane back to LAX, and when I got off the plane, there was
我没有料到会有这个回应。我知道，我也是。嗨，珍娜和安吉拉，办公室女士们，美丽的办公室女士们。所以我的试镜过程，实际上，我没有为《办公室》试镜，但它是以一种有趣的方式来到我这里的。首先，我在密歇根甚至还呆满24小时，就被一部电影开除了，因为其中一个金主觉得我太丑了。所以我的丑屁股就被塞进一架回LAX的飞机上，当我下飞机的时候，有
a message from my agent saying, oh, they want you for the office tomorrow. So I was thrilled. I'd been crying for, I don't know, five hours on a plane, and then I get this news and it's like, yes, I'm so glad I got fired. So when I got to the set the next day, I was a little raw from being told how ugly I was and I was in my dressing room or my trailer, and one of the PAs came and said, oh, something to the effect of, yeah, you don't look as bad as we thought you were going to. So we don't need to see you right away in the makeup chair.
一条我经纪人的留言，说，哦，他们明天想要你演《办公室》。所以我当时欣喜若狂。我在飞机上哭了，我不知道，有五个小时，然后我得到了这个消息，就像是，太好了，真高兴我被解雇了。所以当我第二天到片场时，因为被告知我有多丑，我情绪还有点脆弱，我当时在化妆间或我的房车里，一个制片助理过来说，哦，大意是，是的，你看起来没我们想象的那么糟糕。所以我们不需要马上在化妆椅上见你。
I swear it was something like that. It was like, oh, we're delighted that you don't look like Shrek type of thing. Wendy, I mean, we've all had moments like that. That is something about show business where people can get real tacky. Oh, yeah. Well, you know my story where they said I couldn't be on alias because I wasn't hot enough. But then the very next week I auditioned for a different pilot and they said I was too
我发誓就是类似这样的话。就像是，哦，我们很高兴你看起来不像怪物史莱克。温迪，我的意思是，我们都经历过那样的时刻。演艺界就是有这样一种现象，人们会变得非常俗气。噢，是的。好吧，你知道我的故事，他们说我不能演《双面女间谍》，因为我还不够性感。但就在接下来的一周，我去为一个不同的试镜，他们说我对于这个角色来说太
good looking for the role. So I was like, well, I don't know what I am then. I don't know. Well, I can't change my face. I had an agent say to me, you're not Hollywood glamorous, okay? And I said, I know that. I was like, yeah, I know that. Can I be Hollywood dorky though?
好看了。所以我当时想，好吧，那我都不知道我是什么了。我不知道。好吧，我无法改变我的脸。我曾有一个经纪人对我说，你不是好莱坞迷人的那种，好吧？我说，我知道。我当时就想，是的，我知道。那我能做个好莱坞式的书呆子吗？
You can. Thank you. You did it. And I did it. Oh, no, gosh. And I've been fired. I was fired from a pilot that I did with Matt LeBlanc. I played his wife.
你可以。谢谢你。你做到了。我做到了。哦，不，天哪。而且我被解雇了。我从一个和马特·勒布朗合作过的试镜剧里被解雇了。我演他的妻子。
It's on the air still, man, with a plan. I was his wife. That was my part. Well, I know this story and you shared it in your book. I did. Yeah. I got hired. I shot the pilot.
它现在还在播，老兄，有计划的那部。我是他的妻子。那是我的角色。好吧，我知道这个故事，你在你的书里分享过。我分享过。是的。我被雇用了。我拍了试镜剧。
While I was there, the network said they wanted more scenes with me. I was like, I am nailing it. More scenes means you're doing a good job. Well, I guess after we finished it, they showed it to focus groups. And they didn't like you? No. They liked me, but they said, this is a literal quote. They said, I don't believe Pam would marry Joey.
我在那里的时候，电视网说他们想要更多我和他的对手戏。我当时想，我太成功了。更多对手戏意味着你干得不错。好吧，我想在我们拍完后，他们把它放给焦点小组看。他们不喜欢你吗？不。他们喜欢我，但他们说，这是一句原话。他们说，我不相信帕姆会嫁给乔伊。
The chemistry doesn't work between these two. That was the feedback they got. They could only see you as Pam and Joey. Yeah. So it wasn't working for them that we got married and had a family. And you know, the show is called Man with a Plan. It's starring Matt LeBlanc. It's his show.
这两个人之间没有化学反应。那是他们得到的反馈。他们只能把你当成帕姆和乔伊。是的。所以我们结婚并组建家庭对他们来说行不通。而且你知道，这部剧叫《辣妈妙爸》。由马特·勒布朗主演。这是他的剧。
Yeah, I haven't seen it. Okay. Well, guess who? They can't fire the man with the plan. So out the door, I went. I revenge didn't watch. Thank you. I appreciate it.
对，我没看过。好吧，猜猜怎么着？他们不能解雇有计划的那个人。所以，我出门了。我出于报复没看。谢谢。我很感激。
That's your pee. That's what you're supposed to do. That's right. You fired my BFF. I'm going to watch your show. But here's the crazy part, lady. The crazy part is that I didn't know I was fired until literally like two days before they were going to announce it at the big press junket in New York.
那是你的屁。那是你应该做的。没错。你解雇了我的好闺蜜。我要看你的剧。但最疯狂的部分是，女士。最疯狂的部分是，直到大概在纽约大型记者会上宣布的前两天，我才知道自己被解雇了。
I had packed a suitcase. Tacky. Because everyone was like, it's going. It's going to go. Tacky. It's a sure thing. I had hired hair and makeup to get me ready for all the press. And then I get this call and everyone's on the phone.
我甚至已经打包好行李箱了。俗气。因为每个人都说，这剧要成了。这剧肯定能播。俗气。稳了。我甚至请了发型师和化妆师来为我准备所有的采访。然后我接到这个电话，所有人都在电话里。
All my agents. There's my manager. My 15 people. Publicist. Listen, when there's 15 people on the phone, it's either great news or real, real bad. Yeah. And the first thing I said was, is it not getting picked up? And they said, it's worse than that.
我所有的经纪人。我的经理也在。我的15个人。公关。听着，当电话里有15个人的时候，要么是好消息，要么是极其糟糕的消息。对。我说的第一句话是，这剧没被续订吗？他们说，比那还糟糕。
And I was like, what's worse than that? They said, it's getting picked up, but without you. And I was like, wow, I guess I'll unpack my suitcase. Dang. Yeah. I almost cut bangs in my hair that day. I remember. You stopped me.
我当时就问，还有什么比这更糟糕的？他们说，剧被续订了，但没有你。然后我想，哇，看来我得把行李箱打开了。该死。是的。我那天差点给自己剪了个刘海。我记得。你阻止了我。
I didn't want you to cut your hair that day. I said, you know what? Let's pick a different day. Let's pick a different day to change your whole look. You did send me a picture though of you jumping in the air flipping off the world. I did. I said, that's better. Go jump around, flip off anyone you want in the air, do not cut your hair today.
我不想你那天剪头发。我说，你知道吗？我们选个别的日子吧。选个别的日子来改变你整体的造型。不过你确实发给我一张你跳在空中向世界竖中指的照片。我发了。我说，这样好多了。去到处跳吧，在空中向你想竖中指的任何人竖中指，今天千万别剪头发。
You were a good friend of me that day. And I will never watch that show. Sorry, Matt LeBlanc. I actually love you. And I love Joey, but I'm sorry. I liked Matt LeBlanc too. He was very nice. Anyway.
你那天对我来说是个好朋友。我永远不会看那个节目。对不起，马特·勒布朗。其实我挺喜欢你的。我也喜欢乔伊，但不好意思。我也喜欢马特·勒布朗。他人很好。不管怎样。
All right. Well, Wendy, I am sorry you got fired because you are a talent and a force and I love you. Yes. And thank you for texting me, emailing me. Let's see. Fact number two, Michael goes on his business trip to Winnipeg in this episode and we got a lot of questions from people, why Winnipeg? How did they choose this location?
好吧。好吧，温迪，我很遗憾你被解雇了，因为你是个天才，是个狠角色，我爱你。是的。谢谢你给我发短信、发邮件。接下来，第二条事实，迈克尔在本集去了温尼伯进行商务旅行，我们收到了很多人的提问，为什么是温尼伯？他们是怎么选择这个地点的？
Well, like I said before, this episode was written by Brent Forrester and he did an interview. You mean to the CBC, Jenna? That's the one, and did you find it as well? It's the- Did we both Google real good this episode? Googled real good. CBC is the Canadian broadcast company. Yes.
嗯，就像我之前说的，这一集是由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧的，他接受过一次采访。你是说对CBC的采访，珍娜？就是那个，你找到了吗？那是——我们俩这一集谷歌搜得都很棒吧？谷歌搜得太棒了。CBC是加拿大广播公司。是的。
I'm so proud that I know what CBC stands for. Well, they asked him, why Winnipeg? They did. Some good journalism. He explained that they knew they wanted this to be an international business trip, that they tossed around the idea of Montreal or Vancouver, but in the end they chose Winnipeg because it seemed to strike the right balance between quote, exotic and obscure. Yes.
我为自己知道CBC代表什么而感到骄傲。好吧，他们问他，为什么是温尼伯？他们确实问了。很有水平的新闻采访。他解释说，他们知道这必须是一次国际商务旅行，他们曾考虑过蒙特利尔或温哥华，但最后他们选择了温尼伯，因为它似乎在所谓的“异国情调”和“默默无闻”之间找到了恰当的平衡。是的。
And you know what else I loved in this interview? Brent shared that Phil Shea, our prop master, reached out to the Winnipeg Tourism Promotion Agency and they sent along all kinds of stuff like airport baggage tags, shopping bags from the Bay, old Dutch potato chips, which was founded in Winnipeg in 1954. And you're going to see those on the bar? I became obsessed. Maybe because I watched this episode while I was hungry, I will have some old Dutch potato chip tracking and also flavors to share with you.
你知道我还喜欢这次采访的什么地方吗？布伦特透露，我们的道具主管菲尔·谢伊联系了温尼伯旅游推广局，他们寄来了各种各样的东西，比如机场行李标签、The Bay百货公司的购物袋、老荷兰薯片——该品牌于1954年在温尼伯创立。你会在酒吧里看到这些吗？我变得着迷了。也许是因为我饿着肚子看这一集，我会吃一些老荷兰薯片，还有一些口味要与大家分享。
I'm there for it. And also they sent some Fort Gary Brewing Company paraphernalia and all kinds of other stuff. Yes, because we did not go to Winnipeg. We shot this whole episode in Los Angeles. So we had to just make it look as canada as possible. Fakie canada. Yes.
我举双手赞成。而且他们还寄了一些加里堡酿酒公司的纪念品和各种其他东西。是的，因为我们没有去温尼伯。我们这一整集都是在洛杉矶拍的。所以我们必须让它看起来尽可能像加拿大。山寨加拿大。是的。
Fast fact number three, even though we didn't go to Winnipeg, I have some fun facts about Winnipeg and these were all sent in by fans. Oh, I love it. These ladies listeners who are from Winnipeg wanted us to know these things. So first from Leah Patterson, Winnie the Pooh was named after the city of Winnipeg. Get out. I didn't know that. I didn't know that.
第三条趣味事实，尽管我们没有去温尼伯，但我有一些关于温尼伯的有趣事实，这些都是粉丝们发来的。哦，我喜欢。这些来自温尼伯的听众想让我们知道这些事情。首先来自利亚·帕特森，小熊维尼的名字取自温尼伯市。别开玩笑了。我不知道。我也不知道。
Yeah. A lot of people know that the writer of Winnie the Pooh had a son named Christopher Robin and his son Christopher Robin had a little stuffed bear named Winnie. And that's where he got the idea for the characters. But do you know why his son named his bear Winnie? I do. Why? I don't know.
对。很多人知道《小熊维尼》的作者有一个儿子叫克里斯托弗·罗宾，他的儿子克里斯托弗·罗宾有一只小毛绒熊叫维尼。这就是他获得角色灵感的来源。但你知道为什么他的儿子把他的熊叫维尼吗？我知道。为什么？我不知道。
Oh. I'm just messing with you. I have no idea. There's probably a small number of people that know this, right? Well, I don't know. Leah Patterson knows. Okay, Leah, why? Because in 1915, a black bear was rescued by a cavalry veterinarian who named the bear
哦。我逗你玩的呢。我完全不知道。可能只有极少数人知道这个，对吧？嗯，我不知道。利亚·帕特森知道。好吧，利亚，为什么？因为在1915年，一只黑熊被一名骑兵兽医救了，他给这只熊起名为
Winnie after his hometown of Winnipeg. And then he gave the bear to the London Zoo. And that's where the real Christopher Robin saw the bear, loved the bear, and then named his little stuffed bear after Winnie. Oh. So it's a little roundabout. It's hard to explain. Yeah.
维尼，以他的家乡温尼伯命名。然后他把这只熊送给了伦敦动物园。真正的克里斯托弗·罗宾就是在那里看到了这只熊，喜欢上了这只熊，然后用维尼的名字给他自己的小毛绒熊命名。哦。所以有点曲折。很难解释。对。
I'm sorry if I took you on a real circle there. But the bottom line is, yes, Winnie the Pooh is named after the city of Winnipeg. Well, Leah, I love knowing that. What else you got? More from Leah. More from Leah. Yes. Okay.
如果我刚才带你们绕了个大弯，我很抱歉。但底线是，是的，小熊维尼的名字确实是根据温尼伯市命名的。好吧，利亚，我很高兴知道这一点。你还有什么？利亚发来的更多内容。更多来自利亚的内容。是的。好吧。
Winnipeg has been the slurpy capital of the world for almost 20 years. Wait, like slurpy? Like you get it at 7-Eleven? That's right. I literally sell the most slurpees every year. Come on. Yep. My kids love a slurpee.
温尼伯成为世界“思乐冰之都”已经将近20年了。等等，就像思乐冰？那种你在7-11买到的？没错。他们确实每年卖出最多的思乐冰。开玩笑吧。是的。我的孩子们喜欢思乐冰。
I looked it up. It's true. Gotta go to Winnipeg. More from Leah. Okay. Leah, you are a treasure trove of information about Winnipeg. Where do you work? Do you work at the tourism promotion agency?
我查过了。这是真的。得去一趟温尼伯。利亚还有更多料。好吧。利亚，你真是个关于温尼伯的信息宝库。你在哪上班？你在旅游推广局工作吗？
You should. Winnipeg was also the first city in North America to use 9-1-1. They invented 9-1-1? I don't know. They were the first city to use it. It happened in 1959. Wow. This one from Taylor Nacorato, Winnipeg can get to close to negative 30 degrees Celsius
你应该去的。温尼伯也是北美第一个使用9-1-1的城市。他们发明了9-1-1？我不知道。他们是第一个使用的城市。这发生在1959年。哇。这条来自泰勒·纳卡拉托，温尼伯可以达到接近零下30摄氏度
in the winter, and we have actually broken a record for being colder than the planet Mars in 2019. This is a tough sell for Winnipeg. On New Year's Eve, the Mars Curiosity rover posted a temperature of negative 29 degrees Celsius. Now, that's actually very warm for Mars? Yeah. If you are interested, the average temperature on Mars is about negative 55 degrees Celsius,
的冬天，我们在2019年甚至打破了一项纪录，比火星还要冷。这对温尼伯来说可不是什么好广告。在除夕夜，火星上的“好奇号”漫游车记录的温度是零下29摄氏度。现在，这其实对火星来说很暖和？对。如果你感兴趣的话，火星上的平均气温大约是零下55摄氏度，
but it can get as cold as negative 150 degrees Celsius at the poles. But on this warm day on Mars, it was negative 29, and on that same day in Winnipeg, it was colder than Mars by a few degrees. Dang. Very cold. Taylor N would like you to know that Winnipeg is a very diverse multicultural city, and they host something called Folk Larama. It's one of the largest and longest running multicultural festivals in the world.
但在两极可以冷到零下150摄氏度。但在火星这个温暖的日子里，温度是零下29度，而在温尼伯的同一天，它比火星还要冷好几度。该死。非常冷。泰勒·N想让你知道温尼伯是一个非常多样化的多元文化城市，他们举办一项名为“Folklorama”的活动。它是世界上规模最大、历史最悠久的多元文化节日之一。
It has over 40 pavilions where they embrace cultures of different countries, and you can watch singing and dancing and sample different foods from that country. I would go to that. That sounds so fun. I would love that. Well, listen, I think we should take a break. I think that's a good idea. We'll get an iced tea.
它有40多个展馆，融合了不同国家的文化，你可以观看歌舞并品尝来自该国不同的美食。我会去那儿。听起来太有趣了。我很乐意去。好吧，听着，我想我们该休息一下了。我觉得这是个好主意。我们要去喝杯冰茶。
We're going to come back, and I'm excited to break down business trip. Let's do it. All right, you guys, we are back. We are in the conference room. Michael is teaching the group about various cultures and how to travel to those cultures. International behaviors. Yes. Jenna, background catch.
我们马上回来，我很高兴能剖析商务旅行这一集。我们开始吧。好了，各位，我们回来了。我们在会议室里。迈克尔正在向大家介绍各种文化以及如何去这些文化背景的地方旅行。国际行为。是的。珍娜，背景抓包。
At eight seconds, you can see Kate staring at me, but I can tell it's Kate and not Meredith. She's kind of looking at me like, and then very quickly in the corner, you can see me futzing with my microphone. Oh, was she trying to tell you we could see your microphone? I think something happened. Either my microphone dropped and I was trying to fix it, and Kate was trying to be like, camera's coming, something. There's a moment here.
在8秒的时候，你可以看到凯特在盯着我，但我能看出那是凯特而不是梅雷迪思。她有点看着我，然后非常快地在角落里，你可以看到我在摆弄我的麦克风。哦，她是想告诉你我们能看到你的麦克风吗？我觉得发生了什么事。要么是我的麦克风掉了，我想把它修好，而凯特想暗示说，摄像机要来了，诸如此类。这里有个小插曲。
Yeah, but you can see me, it's very quick. I'm like futzing with my collar doing something. Yeah. Anyway, it's a good catch. Oh, that tickled me. It tickled me. Well, the reason for this conference room scene is so that Michael can explain to us that he is being sent to woo an international client.
对，但你能看到我，动作非常快。我像是在摆弄我的领子，在做什么。不管怎样。是个不错的抓包。哦，这把我逗乐了。把我逗乐了。好吧，这场会议室戏份的原因是迈克尔要向我们解释他被派去追求一个国际客户。
Right. This whole meeting could have been an email. Yeah. Yeah. The other thing that's happening is we learn that Pam is coming home in 6.5 days. Yes, and the office is very excited for Jim. When at Dunder Mifflin, Kevin smacks his butt, Creed gives him a kind of a creepy shoulder rub.
没错。这场会议本可以发个邮件解决的。对。对。另一件发生的事是，我们得知帕姆将在6.5天后回家。是的，办公室里的人为吉姆感到非常兴奋。在邓德米弗林，凯文拍了拍他的屁股，克里德给了他一个有点毛骨悚然的肩膀按摩。
Phyllis smiles and says one more week. When Phyllis smiles and says one more week, please look at her desk. It is covered with tissues. I don't know what was happening. Oh, she must have had a cold. Something. I just love the fact that we didn't bother to tidy the desk. No, it's real life.
菲利斯微笑着说，还剩一周。当菲利斯微笑着说还剩一周时，请看她的办公桌。上面全是纸巾。我不知道发生了什么。哦，她一定感冒了。什么的。我只是喜欢我们懒得去收拾桌子这一点。不，这是真实生活。
It's real life mixed with fake life. Stanley gives Jim a look and goes, eh, eh. And in a deleted scene, Jenna Kelly helps Jim make a sign saying, welcome back. And she's really annoyed because he needs to use more glitter. Oh, yeah. We had a fan question from Chris S. about this scene with Jim. Chris said, I would like to know the specific stage direction Creed was given when he massages Jim's shoulders as he comforts him.
这是真实生活与虚假生活的结合。斯坦利看了吉姆一眼，说，嗯，嗯。在一个删减片段中，珍娜饰演的凯利帮吉姆制作了一个写着“欢迎回来”的牌子。她真的很恼火，因为他需要用更多的亮片。哦，是的。我们有一个来自克里斯·S的粉丝提问，关于吉姆的这场戏。克里斯说，我想知道当克里德安慰吉姆并给他按摩肩膀时，导演给克里德的具体舞台指示是什么。
He really liked this moment. I looked it up in the script. What did it say? In the script, it actually said this, quote, Creed passes Jim. He punches Jim's shoulder and then musts Jim's hair. So this massage, they must have found it on the day because in the script, he was supposed to give him a punch and a hair mess. Well, I think it's funnier because Kevin's already smacked his butt.
他真的很喜欢这个时刻。我在剧本里查了查。上面是怎么写的？在剧本里，它其实是这样写的，引述：“克里德从吉姆身边走过。他打了吉姆的肩膀一下，然后把吉姆的头发弄乱。”所以这个按摩，他们肯定是在拍摄当天现场发挥的，因为在剧本里，他本来应该打他一下并把头发弄乱的。好吧，我觉得这样更有趣，因为凯文已经拍过他的屁股了。
Yeah. So it's like a smack and a punch. I think this is way funnier. So John Krasinski's reactions to everyone, that's what makes it, his face when Creed comes up behind him is so good. So now Michael is on the phone with David Wallace. He's got his passport ready. He's got his per diem.
对。所以就像是拍一下再打一下。我觉得这样有趣多了。所以约翰·卡拉辛斯基对所有人的反应，这才是精髓所在，当克里德走到他身后时他的表情太棒了。现在迈克尔在和大卫·华莱士打电话。他已经准备好护照了。他拿到了他的每日津贴。
50 bucks. He's going to buy a sweater. He is. He'll use other money for food. Yeah. And he has a plane ticket. He does on Butte Airlines. Butte Airlines.
50块钱。他打算买件毛衣。他会的。他会用别的钱买吃的。对。他有一张机票。他确实有，在孤峰航空。孤峰航空。
Well, I think it's probably Butte. I looked it up. I did too. I found nothing. I found Zilch. Not an airline. Not real. Fakie airline.
好吧，我觉得大概是 Butte。我查过了。我也查了。什么也没找到。一无所获。根本不是一家航空公司。假的航空公司。
I want to know more though. Why they settled on Butte? I think it was Butte. Oh, come on, really? I don't know. Why would you call it Butte airline? I don't know. We don't know.
不过我想知道更多。为什么他们定下 Butte？我觉得是 Butte。哦，拜托，真的吗？我不知道。你为什么会叫它 Butte 航空？我不知道。我们不知道。
We're sorry. Sorry guys. It could be Butte or Butte. But it's a Fakie airline. Oh, here's something. Michael is going to bring two extra giant suitcases for souvenirs. Empty. Empty.
对不起。抱歉各位。可能是 Butte 或者是 Butte。但这是一架山寨航空公司。哦，这里有个事。迈克尔打算带两个额外的巨大行李箱来装纪念品。空的。空的。
They're empty. Do you do that? Do you bring an extra empty bag? Do you leave room? As you're packing, do you consider I can't pack this totally full because I know I'm going to purchase something or are you the person who gets to your vacation and it's time to go home and then you have to go buy like an extra canvas bag to get all your stuff home?
它们是空的。你会这样做吗？你会带一个额外的空包吗？你会留出空间吗？当你打包时，你会不会考虑，我不能把这个塞得太满，因为我知道我要买点东西；或者你是那种到了度假地，准备回家了，然后不得不去买一个额外的帆布包才能把所有东西带回家的人？
Ding, ding, ding. Yeah. That's me. Yeah. That's why I have a plethora of real rando bags. Because usually you're in a tight spot and you don't have a lot of options. I once had a travel bag that looked like a zebra because I had to buy it at the airport to fit my souvenirs because my suitcase was starting to like, yeah, start to look like
叮，叮，叮。对。那就是我。对。这就是为什么我有一大堆各种各样的乱七八糟的包。因为通常你处于紧要关头，而且没有太多选择。我曾经有一个旅行包，看起来像斑马，因为我不得不为了装纪念品而在机场买它，因为我的行李箱开始像……对，开始看起来像
it was going to tear. And for a long time, we had the zebra suitcase. Yeah. Yeah. Guess which one I am. You're the first one. I leave the room. You leave the room.
快要撕裂了。而且很长一段时间，我们都用那个斑马纹行李箱。是啊。是啊。你猜我是哪一个。你是第一个。我离开房间。你离开房间。
I anticipate my souvenir purchases. You're not walking through an airport with a zebra bag. No rando bags for me. I'm a rando bag. Listen, rando bag happened to me once, never again. You know what I'm saying? Yeah. Like I have a random suitcase from Scotland.
我预料到了我会买纪念品。你才不会带着斑马纹包包走过机场。我可不要什么随机的包。我就是一个随机的包。听着，我以前遇到过随机包，再也不要了。你知道我在说什么吗？对啊。就像我有一个从苏格兰买来的奇怪行李箱。
I still love it. It looks like a travel trunk from like Joe versus the volcano. This is the problem. Sometimes you get a real find when you're in a bind. I know. Oh, I rhymed it. You did. You are.
我还是超爱它。它看起来就像电影《笨贼妙探》里的那种旅行箱。这就是问题所在。有时候你在窘境中会淘到好货。我知道。哦，我押韵了。你确实押韵了。你就是。
Stop it. If you can pause on rhyming, I want to tell you one other thing that's happening in this scene. I can. Can you? I can try. Okay. I was going to try to rhyme, but I couldn't think of anything.
别这样。如果你能暂停押韵，我想告诉你这幕戏里发生的另一件事。我可以。真的吗？我可以试试。好吧。我本来想试着押韵，但我想不出什么词。
I know. I know. I was trying to set you up. Anyway, while this whole suitcase business is happening, lady in the background, I am telling you Pam's puffer coat is hanging on the coat rack. It's not Pam's coat. Come on. It's not her coat.
我知道。我知道。我刚才是在给你抛梗。不管怎样，就在这整个行李箱事件上演的时候，背景里的那位女士，我跟你说，潘的蓬蓬外套就挂在衣帽架上。那不是潘的外套。得了吧。那才不是她的外套。
How do you know? My buddy wrote in about it and I zoomed in on it. It's not my coat. It sure looks like your coat. It's not mine. Who wrote in? It was me. Angela K wrote in several times.
你怎么知道？我的一个哥们发信来提到了这个，然后我把画面放大了。那才不是我的外套。那看起来绝对像你的外套。才不是我的。是谁发信来的？是我。安吉拉·K发了好几次信。
More mail than anyone. I zoomed in too, and it sure looks like that puffer coat you used to wear. I know it looks like it, but it's not my puffer coat. I think it might be Meredith's. Meredith's had a similar puffer coat. Okay. Well, there you go. Mm-hmm.
比任何人都多。我也放大了，那看起来确实很像你以前常穿的那件蓬蓬外套。我知道它看起来很像，但那真的不是我的蓬蓬外套。我觉得那可能是梅雷迪思的。梅雷迪思有一件类似的蓬蓬外套。好吧。那就对了。嗯-hmm。
Mm-hmm. Guess who else gets to come on this trip? Besides the money belt and the two empty suitcases? Yeah. Andy is going to join him as his translator. He will be translating all of the French that they don't speak in Winnipeg. Well, we did learn in a deleted scene in dinner party, Angela said that Andy learned French during his semester in France.
嗯-hmm。你猜还有谁能加入这次旅行？除了钱腰包和两个空行李箱？对啊。安迪将作为他的翻译随行。他将负责翻译他们在温尼伯时听不懂的所有法语。好吧，我们在《晚宴派对》的删减片段里确实听说过，安吉拉说过安迪在法国留学期间学过法语。
So this is kind of a callback. Kind of a callback. Then Andy speaks some not great French. Oh, a lot of not great French. Mixed in with some Spanish. Oscar is also going on the trip. I don't really know Oscar's role. Why would he be going?
所以这有点像是个前后呼应。有点像个前后呼应。然后安迪说了一些不太流利的法语。哦，大量的极不流利的法语。还夹杂着一些西班牙语。奥斯卡也要去这次旅行。我其实不太清楚奥斯卡的职责。他为什么要去？
Something to do with crunching numbers, maybe? Maybe. I'm so glad that Oscar went because, Jenna, there are so many fantastic deleted Oscar scenes and Oscar and Andy scenes. If you have the DVDs and you guys, Oscar does that thing in these deleted scenes. Like what he did with Holly in employee transfer, I have a new term for Oscar. He's the office fun stopper. Oh, you might think it's Angela Barton, but kind of like Debbie Downer on SNL.
也许跟处理数字有关吧？也许吧。我真的很高兴奥斯卡去了，因为，珍娜，有太多棒极了的奥斯卡以及奥斯卡和安迪的删减片段了。如果你有DVD的话，大家伙们，奥斯卡在这些删减片段里的表现真是绝了。就像他在《员工调动》里对霍利做的那样，我对奥斯卡有了一个新称呼。他是办公室的快乐终结者。哦，你可能会觉得是安吉拉·巴顿，但其实有点像周六夜现场里的黛比·唐纳。
Oscar is always going to have that sidebar comment that's a little too honest for the moment. Takes the wind out of your sails. Takes the wind out of your sails. All right. So now they're on the plane. Michael is up in business class. He's got a mimosa.
奥斯卡总是会发表那种对当时的气氛来说未免太诚实的局外评论。就像给你的帆泄了气。就像给你的帆泄了气。好了。所以现在他们在飞机上了。迈克尔在商务舱。他有一杯含含羞草鸡尾酒。
He has a moist hand towel that's still wet. We got a lot of fan questions from Kyle T, Sarah M, Steph Hernandez, and Madison C. Did you guys film on an actual airplane? If so, which airport and airline were used for this episode? Well, we have some information for you. Yes, we do. Thanks to Randy Cordray, who was our line producer, who took over for Kent Zabornak. He gave us the lowdown.
他有一条还温热的湿手帕。我们收到了来自凯尔·T、萨拉·M、斯特夫·埃尔南德斯和麦迪逊·C的大量粉丝提问。你们是在真正的飞机上拍摄的吗？如果是的话，这个剧集使用了哪个机场和航空公司？好吧，我们有一些信息要告诉大家。是的，我们有。感谢我们的制片主任兰迪·科德雷，他接替了肯·扎博纳克的职务。他向我们透露了内幕。
The interior airplane scenes were filmed at a place called Air Hollywood in Pacoima, California. And at the time, this company was, I guess, like the go-to location for all things airline related. Yeah. It was like a set, but for airplanes, so if you needed a plane to film, they were ready for you. Yeah.
机舱内部的场景是在加利福尼亚州帕科伊马一个叫好莱坞航空的地方拍摄的。在当时，这家公司，我猜，可以说是所有与航空相关的事物首选拍摄地。对啊。它就像是一个片场，不过是为飞机准备的，所以如果你需要一架飞机来拍摄，他们随时为你准备好。对啊。
He said they had all these sound stages. They had various aircraft, various airport-related props. They even had like interior airport kind of stuff. So we used the interior of a jet for Michael in business class and Andy and Oscar and coach. He explained that these airplanes can be split down the middle. Yeah. Well, Michael is going to introduce Oscar and Andy, you know, before they go back to coach, to Beth, who he says is his personal valet slash flight attendant, and she's going
他说他们有所有这些声音舞台。他们有各种飞机，各种与机场相关的道具。他们甚至还有机场内部那种东西。所以我们用了喷气式飞机内部来拍摄迈克尔在商务舱，以及安迪和奥斯卡在经济舱。他解释说这些飞机可以从中间劈开。对啊。好吧，迈克尔要向奥斯卡和安迪介绍，你知道的，在他们回到经济舱之前，介绍给贝丝，他说那是他的私人代客泊车兼空姐，她将会在
to be helping him this morning. I love Beth. I love Beth. When I watched it, it reminded me of the woman who played the transcriber in the deposition. Just no nonsense. Just did we hire an actual flight attendant to play this role? She's so like over Michael and the camera. We did not.
今天早上帮助他。我爱贝丝。我爱贝丝。当我观看时，它让我想起了在《沉积录》里扮演文字记录员的那位女士。就是那种一丝不苟。就是——我们是不是雇了一个真正的空姐来扮演这个角色？她对迈克尔和摄像机的态度简直太不耐烦了。我们没有。
This is an actress. Her name is Deb Height. She has been on The Good Place, Barry, Curb Your Enthusiasm, Veep, Baskets, Arrested Development, Parks and Recreation. She's a writer. She has written plays. She has written award-winning pilots, award-winning short films, and she wrote a comedy book about the rivalry between the Alabama Auburn College football teams called When Mommy Loves Bama
这是一位女演员。她叫黛布·海特。她曾出演过《善地》、《巴里》、《抑制热情》、《副总统》、《巴斯克斯》、《发展受阻》、《公园与游憩》。她是一位作家。她写过戏剧。她写过获奖试播集、获奖短片，她还写过一本关于阿拉巴马大学和奥本大学美式橄榄球校队之间竞争的喜剧书，书名叫《当妈妈爱阿拉巴马》
and Daddy Loves Auburn. You can find it on Amazon. It's really cute. We were so lucky. We say this every week. Oh my gosh. We say it every week. We say every single person hired on the show always crushed it and was amazing.
而爸爸爱奥本》。你可以在亚马逊上找到它。非常可爱。我们太幸运了。我们每周都这么说。哦，天哪。我们每周都这么说。我们说剧组里雇用的每一个人总是表现得极为出色并且超级惊艳。
My favorite moment is when she slams Michael's leg with the cart. I know. It's Steve's reaction, though. Steve's reaction. That was amazing. It's too good. While Michael's getting his foot run over with the beverage cart, Andy is really trying to bond with Oscar back in coach.
我最喜欢的时刻是她用餐车狠狠撞了迈克尔的腿。我知道。不过，是史蒂夫的反应太绝了。史蒂夫的反应。那太惊艳了。太棒了。就在迈克尔的脚被饮料车碾过去的时候，安迪真的在经济舱里努力和奥斯卡搞好关系。
This is a deleted scene. It is amazing. It's Oscar the Fun Stopper, guys. Honey roasted peanuts. Am I right? I don't understand the question. Yes, you're holding a bag of peanuts. I'll save that for later.
这是一段删减片段。这太惊艳了。是快乐终结者奥斯卡，伙计们。蜂蜜烤花生。我说得对吧？我不明白这个问题的意思。是的，你手里正拿着一袋花生。我把它留着以后吃。
That just made me laugh so hard because Andy's like trying to bond. He's like, honey roasted peanuts. But what are you supposed to say to that? I know. I'm with Oscar. I know. But this is my point. Yes.
那真的把我逗得哈哈大笑，因为安迪就像是在努力建立感情。他就像是在说，蜂蜜烤花生。但是面对这个你该说些什么？我知道。我和奥斯卡站在一起。我知道。但这就是我的重点。对啊。
You're holding peanuts. I know. But Oscar cannot edit. I think other people would be like, I know, they're really good or something. But Oscar's just like, I don't understand what you're saying to me. I have to say, I actually really love a honey roasted peanut on an airplane. I do, too. So I would probably respond.
你正拿着花生。我知道。但奥斯卡无法进行顺畅的对话。我觉得其他人可能会说，我知道，它们真的很好吃之类的。但奥斯卡却说，我不明白你对我说这些是什么意思。我必须得说，其实我真的很喜欢飞机上的蜂蜜烤花生。我也是。所以我可能会回应。
I might actually be Andy in this scenario. I just thought that was really good, Oscar the Fun Stopper. But if Oscar's not going to be fun, at least Andy has his DVD player and he's going to watch Harry and the Hindersons. Yeah. I think we should talk about what's happening over at Dunder Mifflin. Oh, yeah. Pam's coming back, which means Ryan is going to have to move into Kelly's nook.
在这种情况下，我可能实际上就是安迪。我只是觉得那真的很好，快乐终结者奥斯卡。但如果奥斯卡不打算带来快乐，至少安迪有他的DVD播放器，他打算看《大脚怪哈里》。对啊。我想我们应该聊聊邓德米弗林那边发生了什么。哦，对啊。潘要回来了，这意味着瑞安将不得不搬进凯利的隔间。
And he's looking for a place he might be able to do his push-ups. He needs space to do push-ups. He does. It's kind of tight and cramped over there, but he's going to try. He's going to find a way. We had a fan question. How many push-ups did BJ have to do in this episode? He must have been so sore.
而且他在找一个也许可以做俯卧撑的地方。他需要空间来做俯卧撑。他确实需要。那边又挤又狭窄，但他会试一试的。他会找到办法的。我们有一个粉丝提问。在这集中BJ必须做多少个俯卧撑？他当时一定酸痛极了。
I want to hear this because I, as Jenna knows, I texted BJ last night and I said, by the way, I just watched you do a one-armed push-up and then business trip. Dang, BJ. Well, I texted with BJ about his push-ups as well. And he said he doesn't remember how many takes they did, but he said that Mindy definitely wrote this scene. He said there was a period of time when all the writers were doing push-up contests, and that might have inspired it, but also at the same time, he was in training because he was
我很想听听这个，因为正如珍娜所知，我昨晚给BJ发短信说，顺便说一句，我刚看你做了一个单臂俯卧撑，然后就是《商务旅行》。厉害了，BJ。好吧，我也和BJ短信聊过关于他俯卧撑的事。他说他不记得他们拍了多少条，但他说了这个场景绝对是敏迪写的。他说曾有一段时间，所有的作家都在进行俯卧撑比赛，这可能启发了她，但同时，他在进行训练，因为他正在
prepping to do the Tarantino movie in Glorious Bastards. Oh yeah. He was getting in really good shape for that because he was going to be a soldier. Yeah. So he was doing push-ups in the writer's room all the time. He had to literally find room to do push-ups at work. So Mindy might have been going off of that as well. But also, maybe she just wanted to make BJ have to do a bunch of push-ups in a scene.
为昆汀的电影《无耻混蛋》做准备。哦，对啊。他当时为了那个在做非常好的身体训练，因为他要演一个士兵。对啊。所以他一直在编剧室里做俯卧撑。他不得不字面意义上在工作时找空间来做俯卧撑。所以敏迪可能也是从那里面获得的灵感。但也有可能，她只是想让BJ不得不在一个场景里做好多俯卧撑。
And then a one-armed push-up. Yeah. See, that's a moment where if I'm BJ, I'm like, I'm so glad I got that on camera that I did it at least once. That I could do it. Yeah. I'll always have that. Well, listen, Kelly is claiming she's not impressed.
然后还要做一个单臂俯卧撑。对啊。你看，那就是那种时刻，如果我是BJ，我会觉得，我太庆幸自己把那段录下来了，至少我做过一次。我能做到。对啊。我会永远拥有这个回忆。好吧，听着，凯利声称她并没有被打动。
Ryan has hurt her too much. It is not going to happen. No. She is in a healthy relationship with Daryl. That door is closed. Cut to. Major make-out. That's kissy sounds.
瑞安伤她太深了。这不可能发生。不。她和达里尔处于一段健康的恋爱关系中。那扇门已经关上了。镜头切到。激烈的亲吻。那是接吻的声音。
Yeah. I could tell. Oh, you could. Yeah. One, one, one, one. One, one, one. You did it. Back in Winnipeg, the guys are arriving at the hotel.
对啊。我听得出来。哦，你听得出来。对啊。一，一，一，一。一，一，一。你做到了。回到温尼伯，这几个人到达了酒店。
It's so beautiful. Michael says he could live there. We had a fan catch from Tori, Mary, and Katie who said, Michael left Dunder Mifflin with multiple suitcases, but he shows up at the hotel with only his carry-on. What happened to his souvenir suitcases? Well, guys, I'll tell you, they're there. You have to look deep in the background. At six minutes, 37 seconds, you can see the bellman loading the suitcases onto a trolley.
太美了。迈克尔说他可以住在那里。我们收到了来自托里、玛丽和凯蒂的粉丝抓包，他们说，迈克尔离开邓德米弗林时带着好几个行李箱，但他到酒店时却只带了随身行李。他那些纪念品行李箱怎么了？好吧，伙计们，我来告诉你们，它们在那儿。你得往背景深处仔细看。在6分37秒的时候，你可以看到行李员正把行李箱搬上手推车。
Oh. As Michael goes up, snap, the escalator. Nice. So don't worry. He has them, and he's going to get those souvenirs. Yeah. They're going to put them in his room. Jenna, this hotel has something sort of magical about it, fantastical.
哦。当迈克尔上去时，啪，电梯。太棒了。所以不用担心。他有那些行李箱，他会拿到那些纪念品的。对啊。他们会把这些放到他的房间里。珍娜，这家酒店有一种神奇的、奇幻的特质。
It's called a concierge. Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm. I don't know if you've ever heard of it. Oh, yeah. You know, they help you with the fine art of fanciness and pleasure. These guys are going to try it out. They're going to go over and they're going to ask her a bunch of questions.
它叫做礼宾部。哦，对啊。嗯-hmm。我不知道你有没有听说过。哦，对啊。你知道的，他们帮你领略高级感和快乐的精妙艺术。这几个人打算去体验一下。他们打算过去，然后问她一堆问题。
And guess what? What? Almost nothing she says is true. But I just love how completely blown away Michael is that she knows restaurants and their street address, and the best way to get there. This is mind-blowing to him. This is such a real concierge interaction when she pulls out the map. The map encircles it and then tells them two different routes and two different means of
你猜怎么着？什么？她说的几乎没有一句是真的。但我就是好喜欢迈克尔对她了解餐馆、街道地址以及去那里的最佳路线这一点感到彻底被震撼的样子。这对他来说简直是脑洞大开。当她掏出地图时，这绝对是一个非常真实的礼宾部互动场景。地图把它圈起来，然后告诉他们两条不同的路线和两种不同的交通
transportation. Perfection. Perfection. But we did have a lot of fans from Winnipeg who wrote in again. Kimberly Kay said, did the writers know that everything concierge Marie said about Winnipeg is inaccurate? Was this on purpose? Oh.
工具。完美。完美。但我们确实收到了很多温尼伯粉丝的再次来信。金伯利·K说，编剧们知道礼宾玛丽关于温尼伯的一切说法都是不准确的吗？这是故意的吗？哦。
Kimberly V said, the number 17 bus is real, but it runs a lot later than 9 p.m. It goes till almost 1 a.m. It wouldn't be the only bus to the exchange district, which does not exist. I think they meant the financial district. And then Leah P said, we also don't have an Astro Cleaners. Or the restaurants or the bar. No, the Huntsman is not a real bar. And neither is the sushi place.
金伯利·V说，17路公交车是真的，但它的运营时间比晚上9点要晚得多。它一直运营到将近凌晨1点。它不会是去交易所区的唯一公交车，而交易所区根本不存在。我想他们指的是金融区。然后莉娅·P说，我们也没有Astro Cleaners干洗店。也没有那些餐馆或酒吧。不，亨茨曼酒吧不是一家真正的酒吧。寿司店也不是。
Yes. Well, Angela, we have another story happening in this episode. It's Pam, right? It's a big story. Well, she's supposed to be coming home from art school, but we're going to have a phone call between her and Jim and they're going to find out some news. She's failing her flash class. Yeah.
是的。好吧，安吉拉，我们在这集中还有另一条故事线。是潘，对吧？这是一条重要的故事线。嗯，她本来应该从艺术学校回来的，但我们将看到她和吉姆之间通一个电话，他们会发现一些消息。她艺术史课不及格了。对啊。
And she's going to have to take it again. If she wants to pass art school, she does. That means she has to stay another 12 weeks. Is this art school like just digital art? Does she get to do any of the art that she's actually really good at? I don't know. It seems like this was mostly a graphic design program. Yeah.
而且她必须重修。如果她想从艺术学校毕业的话，她必须这么做。这意味着她必须多呆12周。这个艺术学校只是学数字艺术吗？她能做任何她真正擅长的艺术吗？我不知道。看起来这主要是一个平面设计专业。对啊。
Well, I had to cry in this scene. It was in the script that I'm holding back tears. And there's a lot that is coming down on Pam right now. She's dealing with the fact that she didn't complete this course and the idea of being away from Jim even longer. But I had something else that I was playing. We'll get to it. Okay.
好吧，我在这一场戏里不得不哭。剧本里就写着我在强忍泪水。而且现在有很多事情向潘扑面而来。她在应付自己没有完成这门课程的事实，以及不得不离开吉姆更长时间的想法。但我当时还在琢磨别的事情。我们待会儿会聊到。好的。
Well, I thought it was a very moving scene and it just reminds me of those moments you guys. When life happens, even though everything around you just keeps moving on, so Pam is sitting down. It's like a busy stairwell. People are going up and down and she's having a life moment. Yeah. I thought that was very relatable.
好吧，我觉得这是一个非常感人的场景，它只是让我想起了你们经历过的那些时刻。当生活发生时，尽管你周围的一切都在继续前进，所以潘正坐在那里。那就像是一个繁忙的楼梯间。人们上上下下，而她正经历着人生的重要时刻。对啊。我觉得这非常有共鸣。
Well, Jenna, back in Winnipeg, the fellows are going to arrive at Huntsman Bar. Yes. We shot these scenes at the seven grand bar and grill in Los Angeles. Did you notice at nine minutes, 20 seconds, what the chalkboard says at the Huntsman? No. This is what it says. Welcome to the Huntsman. Enjoy, quote, pub hour all night, Sunday and Monday, five to seven PM, no creeps allowed.
好吧，珍娜，回到温尼伯，这几位伙伴要到达亨茨曼酒吧了。是的。我们在洛杉矶的“七大酒吧与烧烤”拍摄了这些场景。你有没有注意到在9分20秒时，亨茨曼酒吧的黑板上写着什么？没有。上面是这样写的。欢迎来到亨茨曼。尽情享受，引述，整晚酒吧时光，周日和周一，下午五点到七点，禁止怪人入内。
Oh, wow. Get out creeps. Get out creeps. And I have a background catch. Again, I was hungry as I watched this episode. The chips. The chips, you guys. The chips that Phil Shea got are at the bar.
哦，哇。滚开吧，怪人。滚开吧，怪人。我还有一个背景抓包。再说一次，我看着这一集时觉得饿了。薯片。薯片，你们这些家伙。菲尔·谢伊弄来的薯片就在酒吧里。
Yes. And I think I can see the ketchup flavored chips. They're in a red-n-white- Ketchup flavor. Oh, yes, lady. Why did I do that with my voice? Have you eaten them? Yes.
是的。而且我想我能看到番茄味薯片。它们装在一个红白相间的袋子里——番茄味。哦，是的，女士。我刚才怎么用那种声音说话了？你吃过它们吗？是的。
I've never heard of this item. Well, I worked in Canada for a bit, you know, and I have had these ketchup chips. Jenna, they're so good. Listen to how they're described on the internet. They are the perfect balance of a delightful old Dutch chip layered with that lovely ketchup flavor you desire. But I don't desire a ketchup flavor on my potato chips. Well, it might change your mind.
我从来没听说过这个东西。好吧，我在加拿大工作过一段时间，你知道的，我吃过这种番茄味薯片。珍娜，它们太好吃了。听听互联网上是怎么描述它们的。它们是美味的荷兰老牌薯片与你渴望的那种可爱的番茄风味之间的完美平衡。但我并不渴望在薯片上有番茄味。好吧，这可能会改变你的想法。
I'm just telling you. Maybe I will. Chip people, old Dutch chip people, will you send me a ketchup chip? Oh, my gosh. Get ready. But listen, make sure some come my way. You got it. They're tangy.
我只是告诉你。也许我会的。薯片迷们，荷兰老牌薯片的人，你们能寄给我一包番茄味薯片吗？哦，天哪。准备好。不过听着，一定要顺便给我寄一些来。没问题。它们酸甜可口。
They're delicious. Okay. Guess who else is at the bar? Concierge Marie. Yeah. Michael is, um, how you say, so excited to see her. Yeah. How do you say it?
它们太美味了。好啦。你猜谁也在酒吧里？礼宾玛丽。对啊。迈克尔是，嗯，怎么说呢，见到她太兴奋了。对啊。你怎么说？
How do you say it? Andy's going to bring him two glasses of wine. Mm-hmm. He's going to get things started. Yeah. He's also going to try to get things started for Oscar and a couple of gentlemen sitting at a table nearby. That's right.
你怎么说？安迪要给他拿两杯酒。嗯-hmm。他要开始行动了。对啊。他还要试着为奥斯卡和坐在附近桌子的一对男士开始点单。没错了。
He says to the bartender, Madam Azale, beer me, dose long Island ice teas, sieve au play. Bad decision in a glass. It is a bad decision. It is a horrible decision. You know how you've had a volcano and you did the splits? Yes. I've had some long Island ice teas. Where?
他对酒保说，阿扎勒夫人，给我来杯啤酒，两杯长岛冰茶，请。这是杯中的糟糕决定。这是一个糟糕的决定。这是一个可怕的决定。你知道你曾经喝过火山鸡尾酒然后劈过叉吗？是的。我喝过一些长岛冰茶。在哪里？
In the Bahamas on spring break with my friends. I never had one before. I wasn't 21 yet, but in the Bahamas you can drink when you're 18. We went to the casino and they just give them to you free if you sit at the slot machines. I have not. All of this was like, what is happening? I have not had a long Island ice tea. I've had the volcano, but it's just the same thing.
在巴哈马和朋友们过春假的时候。我以前没喝过。我当时还没满21岁，但在巴哈马，你18岁就可以喝酒。我们去了赌场，如果你坐在老虎机旁，他们就会免费给你提供。我没喝过。所有这一切都像是，发生了什么？我没喝过长岛冰茶。我喝过火山鸡尾酒，但其实是一样的东西。
They just dump a bunch of booze in it, right? It's like seven or eight different liquors. Tasty went down easy. Well, yeah. Then a lot of vomiting. A lot of vomiting. Well, we got a fan question about this scene from Evan L. At 11 minutes, 14 seconds, Andy says, you will thank me when they spank thee.
他们只是在里面倒了一堆烈酒，对吧？就像七、八种不同的烈酒。喝下去的时候觉得味道不错，很容易下咽。好吧。然后就是大量的呕吐。大量的呕吐。好吧，我们收到了一个关于这个场景的粉丝提问，来自埃文·L。在11分14秒时，安迪说，当他们拍你屁股的时候，你会感谢我的。
And he wants to know who came up with that line. Can I guess? Sure. Lee or Jean? That's a good guess. It's in the script and I asked Brent Forrester about it and he said, he is the author of the thank me spank thee line. He said, there are few things more fun than writing a rhyming punchline for the Andy character.
他想知道这句台词是谁想出来的。我能猜一下吗？当然。李还是让？这是个很好的猜测。它就在剧本里，我问过布伦特·福雷斯特关于这件事，他说，他就是“感谢我拍屁股”这句台词的作者。他说，没有什么比为安迪这个角色写一个押韵的点睛之笔更有趣的事了。
He said he got a little bit too into writing rhyming punchlines for Ed that season. He said that one day in the writer's room, he pitched a line where Andy refers to his quote, back up snack pack backpack. And he said at that point, the writers forbid him from writing any more rhyming punchlines for the rest of the year. I wonder if he wrote nifty gifties. He might have. Oh, Brent, that's so good.
他说，那一季他有点太沉迷于为埃德写押韵的包袱了。他说有天在编剧室里，他抛出了一句台词，安迪把他的，引述，备用零食背包背包，称为“零食背包背包”。他说在那之后，编剧们禁止他在这一年的剩余时间里再写任何押韵的包袱。我在想他是不是写了“精美礼品”。他可能写过。哦，布伦特，那太棒了。
Well guess what? They're not going to spank him. They're not. They turn him down. And Oscar and Andy now drink the Long Island Ice Teas, which is going to lead to some trouble. Some real trouble because Oscar says to Andy, what do you see in Angela? And again, I was hungry as I watched this, so at 12 minutes, 17 seconds, I can see another
那你们猜怎么着？他们才不会拍他屁股。他们才不会。他们拒绝了他。现在奥斯卡和安迪喝了长岛冰茶，这将会带来一些麻烦。真正的麻烦，因为奥斯卡对安迪说，你在安吉拉身上看到了什么？再次说明，我看着这一集时觉得饿了，所以在12分17秒时，我可以看到奥斯卡手臂旁的吧台上放着另一袋荷兰老牌薯片。
bag of old Dutch potato chips sitting next to Oscar's arm on the bar. They're the green and white bag. You know what that means. Sour cream and onion. They are the dill pickle chips. What? Yep. Described on the internet.
那是绿白相间的袋子。你知道那意味着什么。酸奶油洋葱味。那是莳萝泡菜味的薯片。什么？是的。互联网上的描述。
Do they make any regular flavors? They do. I'm telling you, these chips are so good. You've had the dill pickle ones? I have sampled. You know, like on set, we would have a whole bunch of bags of chips. They're real salty, and I liked it. I guess I'm a chip traditionalist.
它们有什么常规口味吗？有的。我跟你说，这些薯片太好吃了。你吃过莳萝泡菜味的吗？我尝过。你知道的，在片场，我们总会有好几大包薯片。它们真的很咸，而我很喜欢。我想我是一个薯片传统主义者。
You know what? You need to be a chip traveler. All right. You need to try some international chips. I'll try them. Well, the dill ones are real salty. I do like a pickle. I know.
你知道吗？你需要成为一个薯片旅行者。好吧。你需要尝尝一些国际薯片的风味。我会尝的。好吧，莳萝味的真的很咸。我确实喜欢泡菜。我知道。
But anyway, Andy Drunktiles Angela, this is a huge mistake. Oh, my goodness. He says, you know what, we're going to discuss this. We will discuss this naked. But then there's a voice in the background. I mean, she's with Dwight. Of course she is. Yeah.
但不管怎样，喝醉的安迪给安吉拉打了电话，这是一个巨大的错误。哦，天哪。他说，你知道吗，我们要讨论这个。我们要赤诚相见地讨论这个。但接着背景里传出一个声音。我是说，她和德怀特在一起。她当然在一起。对啊。
But somehow Andy doesn't totally register it. He's had a Long Island iced tea. Several, I think, at this point. But guess what, Michael and Concierge Marie, they're clicking. They're going to leave. They're going to smooch outside in the alley. And we asked Wendy about this, about kissing Steve. And here's what she had to say.
但不知怎的，安迪并没有完全意识到这一点。他喝了一杯长岛冰茶。我想此时已经有好几杯了。但你猜怎么着，迈克尔和礼宾玛丽，他们看对眼了。他们要离开。他们要在外面的小巷里亲热。我们问过温迪关于这事，关于亲吻史蒂夫。这是她当时的说法。
I was super nervous to kiss Steve Carell. I was so nervous that I was practically going into convulsions. But I did it, and it was great, and I highly recommend it. She highly recommends. Oh, well. They're not just going to kiss outside the hotel, all right? We are going to cut to Michael being sort of shoved out of her. Room 887.
我紧张极了，要亲吻史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。我紧张得简直快要抽搐了。但我还是亲了，感觉棒极了，我强烈推荐。她强烈推荐。哦，好吧。他们可不只是在酒店外面亲热，好吗？我们要切到迈克尔被赶出她的房间。887号房间。
Yeah. Without his shoes. Barefoot. He's shuffling down the hall. I know. And then she's like, wait, you forgot your shoes. Only she says nothing. She just sets them out and quickly shuts the door.
对啊。连鞋都没穿。赤脚。他拖着步子走在走廊里。我知道。然后她说，等等，你忘穿鞋了。只不过她什么也没说。她只是把鞋子拿出来，然后迅速关上了门。
Well that kind of wraps up Concierge Marie. We had to ask Wendy if she ever gets recognized for being on the show. And here's what she said. Yes. So many times. I'm so surprised at that, because I was, you know, barely in it. But you know, that just speaks to the reach and the popularity of the office. I read a fun fact about Wendy.
好吧，这差不多就是礼宾玛丽的戏份了。我们不得不问温迪，她是否曾因为出演这部剧而被认出来过。她是这么说的。是的。太多次了。我对此感到非常惊讶，因为我，你知道的，戏份少得可怜。但你知道的，这说明了《办公室》的影响力和受欢迎程度。我读到了关于温迪的一个有趣的事实。
Yes, you did. Share it, Jenna. You did. Okay. Wendy was the editor for California State University's academic Journal of Social Work. This was her day job before she hit it big as an actress. But even after she was working all the time, she kept her job until 2012. Bridesmaids came out in 2011.
是的，你确实读到了。分享一下吧，珍娜。你确实读到了。好吧。温迪曾是加州州立大学学术社会工作期刊的编辑。这是她在作为演员成名之前的主业。但甚至在她工作非常忙之后，她一直保留着这份工作直到2012年。《伴娘》上映于2011年。
So even after Bridesmaids, she was still editing this Journal of Social Work. And we had to ask her about it. Here's what she said. It is true that while I was building my acting career and, you know, doing pretty well that I kept my side job at Cal State Long Beach, I was an assistant editor for a social work journal. I did that for 12 years, all through Reno 911, all through, you know, all these movies that I did, rules of engagement, and right up until the Goldbergs.
所以甚至在《伴娘》之后，她还在编辑这份社会工作期刊。我们不得不问她这件事。她是这么说的。千真万确，当我在建立我的演艺事业，你知道的，做得还不错的时候，我在加州大学长滩分校保留了我的副业，我曾是一家社会工作期刊的助理编辑。我干了12年，经历了整个《雷诺911》，经历了，你知道的，我拍的所有这些电影，《约会规则》，一直到《戈德堡一家》。
And the only reason I'm not doing it anymore is because the journal folded. It went out of business. But it was a great job. It was like not even 20 hours a week. I could do it from wherever I was. And it was all about, you know, people in the social work profession. And let's be honest, those people deserve a lot of credit for what they do. They don't get recognized enough.
我不再做这份工作的唯一原因是因为那本期刊停刊了。它倒闭了。但那是一份很棒的工作。每周甚至不到20个小时。我无论身在何处都可以做。而且它全部是关于，你知道的，社会工作行业里的人们。老实说，这些人因他们的所作所为而值得极高的赞誉。他们没有得到足够的认可。
Yeah, it was great. And I loved doing it. I loved my original boss who used to come and see my shows at the ground, links like she was just so super supportive that she said, please don't ever quit. So I kept my word and I stayed until the very end. See what I was saying about amazing human being. I love her. You know, that was so moving to me when I heard it.
是的，这很棒。我很喜欢做这份工作。我爱我的第一任老板，她以前常来看我在爆笑剧团的演出，她就是那么超级支持我，她说，请千万不要辞职。所以我遵守了承诺，坚持到了最后。看我刚才怎么说来着，她真是一个了不起的人。我太爱她了。你知道的，当我听到这些时，我真的很感动。
My niece is a social worker. I'm just always, you know, honestly, guys, I'm lifting her up in prayer all the time because it's not an easy job. And I'm thankful that we have people that have a passion for helping others in that way. Yeah, it's not an easy job because sometimes you have to see and confront real hard things. Yes. And then you have to hold that. Yeah.
我的侄女是一名社工。我只是总是，你知道的，老实说，伙计们，我一直在祈祷中支持她，因为这不是一份轻松的工作。我很感激我们有这样一群满腔热情以这种方式帮助他人的人。对啊，这不是一份轻松的工作，因为有时你必须面对和直面真正艰难的事情。是的。然后你必须承担这些。对啊。
Yeah. Well, as if you needed another reason to love Wendy, I would also like to share that in 2009, 2010 and 2011, she rang in the New Year performing at military bases in Iraq and Kuwait, and she went to the smaller bases that a lot of people didn't go to that kind of rarely get entertainment. Love that. Love you. Wendy.
对啊。好吧，仿佛你还需要另一个理由去爱温迪，我还想分享的是，在2009年、2010年和2011年，她跨年夜都在伊拉克和科威特的军事基地进行表演，而且她去了许多人不会去的、很少能得到娱乐活动的小型基地。太棒了。爱你。温迪。
Thank you so much. It was so great to reconnect with you. Thanks for sharing your memories of the office. You guys, you can find Wendy in so many places. She's so talented. She has a podcast called Generation Ripe. It is for teenagers over 40. It's described as a generation ripe listener is someone who thinks of their age as an asset,
非常感谢你。能和你重新建立联系真是太棒了。谢谢你分享你对《办公室》的回忆。伙计们，你们可以在很多地方找到温迪。她太有才了。她有一个播客叫《成熟的一代》。它是为40岁以上的青少年准备的。它的描述是：成熟一代的听客是一个把年龄视为资产而非负债的人。
not a liability. We are older people with young souls or younger people with old souls. Of course, she's on the Goldbergs. They're about to start season nine. She's on a Marvel series on Hulu called Modak and just tons of other things, you guys. And you can find her on Instagram at Wendy McClendon Covey. Yes. Let's see.
我们是拥有年轻灵魂的老年人，或者是拥有老成灵魂的年轻人。当然，她出演了《戈德堡一家》。他们正要开始第九季。她还出演了Hulu上的一部漫威剧集《魔爪》，还有数不清的其他作品，伙计们。你可以在Instagram上找到她，账号是Wendy McClendon Covey。好的。让我们看看。
Where should we go? It's the next day. Oh, people are hungover. Very hungover. Andy does not remember calling Angela. I know. Oh, no. Oh.
我们该去哪儿？第二天。哦，大家宿醉了。宿醉得很厉害。安迪不记得给安吉拉打过电话了。我知道。哦，不。哦。
Michael is very melancholy, and he has to go sell paper at Catalyst Paper, which I looked it up. Yeah. It's not a real Canadian paper company, but it looks like its headquarters is based in Richmond, British Columbia, which is over on the West Coast. I could not find a Winnipeg branch. I mean, if you couldn't, I doubt it's there. David Wallace calls to congratulate Michael because he did it.
迈克尔非常忧郁，他必须去凯特利斯纸业卖纸，我查了一下。是的。这不是一家真正的加拿大纸业公司，但看起来它的总部设在不列颠哥伦比亚省的里士满，那是在西海岸。我没找到温尼伯分公司。我是说，如果你都没找到，那它大概率是不存在的。大卫·华尔士打电话来祝贺迈克尔，因为他成功了。
He got the sale. Michael is mad. Yeah. Because he's realized that this trip was a Band-Aid to try to help his feelings about Holly being transferred, he's upset. And he tells him off. Yeah. I have a location breakdown.
他做成了这笔生意。迈克尔很生气。对啊。因为他意识到这次旅行只是一个创可贴，用来缓解他对霍利被调职的情绪，他很沮丧。他把大卫·华尔士痛骂了一顿。对啊。我有了一个地点花絮。
Why do you say it like that? I don't know. You said it like sad sack. You said it like this. I have a location breakdown. Well, I'm sad with Michael. Aw. Yeah.
你为什么用那种语气说话？我不知道。你把它说得像个泄气包。你是这么说的。我有了一个地点花絮。好吧，我和迈克尔一样难过。啊。对啊。
For the Winnipeg Airport for these scenes, we used terminal number two at LAX. Randy let me know that there was an area that was out of service at that time, and that our location manager, Kyle Alexander, was able to get an agreement from the LAX airport to let us film there. That's like unheard of. Well, LAX does not let you film. Like they are hardcore. Well, especially after 9-11, they had incredibly strict airport security.
对于这些温尼伯机场的场景，我们使用了洛杉矶国际机场（LAX）的2号航站楼。兰迪告诉我，当时有一个区域处于暂停服务状态，我们的外景制片人凯尔·亚历山大成功与LAX机场达成了一项协议，允许我们在那里拍摄。这简直是闻所未闻。好吧，LAX是不允许拍摄的。他们态度极其强硬。好吧，尤其是在“9·11”之后，他们有极其严格的机场安保。
So we were only allowed a very small number of cast and crew and extras. Everybody had to submit credentials very far in advance and had to be screened. So he said they had to create what they called a micro unit. That's how small it was. He said that the airplanes outside the window were not Air Canada planes. They had to paint over the logos using visual effects during post-production. And so they put the red maple leaf on the tail of one of the planes. We could only afford to do one plane.
所以我们只被允许携带极少数量的演员、剧组人员和群众演员。每个人都必须提前很久提交身份证明并接受审查。所以他说他们不得不组建了一个他们称之为“微型小队”的团队。就是这么小。他说窗外的飞机并不是加拿大航空公司的飞机。他们不得不在后期制作中使用视觉特效把标志涂掉。于是他们在其中一架飞机的机尾上画上了红枫叶。我们只负担得起画一架飞机。
If you look over Michael's shoulder, it's on the left. Yeah, I saw it. Well before we get to this big business with Jim and Pam, we should probably let you know that Kelly is going to break up with Daryl. I mean, Ryan has a text ready to go. They just have to hit send together. And I think, what does Ryan want? Does he want Daryl to come upstairs and make a scene?
如果你顺着迈克尔的肩膀看过去，它就在左边。对啊，我看到了。好吧，在我们讨论吉姆和潘这件大事之前，我们可能应该告诉大家，凯利要和达里尔分手了。我是说，瑞安已经准备好了一条短信。他们只需要一起按下发送键。我想，瑞安到底想要什么？他想让达里尔上楼来大闹一场吗？
What does Ryan want? He wants to be the other guy. Yeah, he wants a reaction out of Daryl. Daryl seems relieved. He's whistling as he walks through his car. He responds immediately, OK, cool, and then literally is like doing a dance to his pickup truck. Yeah.
瑞安到底想要什么？他想当那个第三者。对啊，他想从达里尔那里得到一个反应。达里尔看起来如释重负。他吹着口哨走向他的车。他立刻回复道，好吧，酷，然后字面意义上像是在跳着舞走向他的小货卡。对啊。
He's like, whoo, thank you, Ryan. And that then, of course, immediately makes Ryan less interested in this relationship. And here we go. And they're back. Here we go. All right, Jim is going to leave. And again, you guys have this Jim and Pam scene. At that golden hour, your hair is sparkling with sunshine.
他就像是，呜呼，谢谢你，瑞安。而这当然立刻让瑞安对这段关系失去了兴趣。我们走吧。他们回来了。我们走吧。好的，吉姆要离开了。再说一次，你们有一个吉姆和潘的场景。在那黄金时刻，你的头发闪烁着阳光。
It's like that sunset scene in the parking lot. You couldn't look cuter. I know. I thought this scene was really sweet. Yeah. Pam is standing in the parking lot and Jim says, what are you doing here? Because he had told her on the phone, when you come back, you're going to come back the right way.
就像停车场那个日落场景一样。你看上去不能再可爱了。我知道。我觉得这个场景真的很温馨。对啊。潘站在停车场里，吉姆说，你在这里干什么？因为他在电话里告诉过她，当你回来时，你要以正确的方式回来。
Right. And he's supportive. If she wants to take the class again, they'll get through it. Yes. That the right way to come back is for her to come back having graduated from art school. So Pam's standing there and she says, I'm coming back the wrong way, but she's okay with it. She's happy about it.
对的。而且他是支持她的。如果她想重修这门课，他们会度过难关的。是的。以正确的方式回来，就是以从艺术学校毕业的身份回来。所以潘站在那里说，我是以错误的方式回来的，但她对此没问题。她对此很高兴。
Yeah. She missed Scranton. She missed Jim. She actually hated the graphic design school. Yeah. She tells Jim, this isn't really what I wanted to do. But she had to go to find that out. She did.
对啊。她想念斯克兰顿。她想念吉姆。她其实讨厌那个平面设计学校。对啊。她告诉吉姆，这并不是她真正想做的事。但她必须去尝试才能发现这一点。她确实去了。
You know, we had a question from Evan L. Why did the writers have Pam fail art school? Well, that's a good question, Evan. I asked Brent Forrester about it. He said that the story of Pam failing art school and coming back, quote, the wrong way was a pitch from Jen Salata. Brent said, I have a daughter. And he said, I'm a big fat feminist. That's a quote.
你知道的，我们收到了埃文·L的一个问题。为什么编剧要让潘艺术学校不及格？好吧，这是个好问题，埃文。我问过布伦特·福雷斯特关于这件事。他说，潘艺术学校不及格并以，引述，“错误的方式”回来的这个故事，是珍·萨拉塔的一个提案。布伦特说，我有一个女儿。并且他说，我是一个彻头彻尾的女权主义者。这是一句引述。
And the idea that Pam would give up on her dreams to be with a man really rubbed him the wrong way, but that Jen Salata absolutely insisted that the romantic power of this gesture outweighed any politics. And also that the truth for Pam was not that she was giving up on her dreams for Jim, but that she was distinguishing what her real dreams were. And I really liked that because I think what Pam did here in going to graphic design school was that she was taking her real dream of being a creative artist. And she was doing what a lot of artists do, and she was trying to find a practical application.
而潘为了一个男人而放弃梦想的想法让他感到非常不舒服，但珍·萨拉塔绝对坚持认为，这种浪漫姿态的力量超过了任何政治考量。并且同时，对潘来说，真相并不是她为了吉姆放弃了自己的梦想，而是她在甄别自己真正的梦想是什么。我真的很喜欢这一点，因为我认为潘在这里去上平面设计学校时，她是在实现自己想成为一名创意艺术家的真正梦想。她正在做很多艺术家都在做的事情，她试图寻找一个实际的应用。
Right. How can I sort of do art but make a living? Yeah. Right? Yes, exactly. But, you know, I mean, people go into graphic design when they're passionate about graphic design. It's not some backup job, right?
对吧？我怎么才能一边做艺术一边谋生呢？对吧？是的，完全正确。但是，你知道的，我的意思是，人们在对平面设计充满热情时才会去学习平面设计。它可不是什么备用工作，对吧？
And the truth is, is that Pam discovered she does not have a passion for graphic design. And that's sort of what I had in my head when I was doing that scene on the phone with Jim and Pam's crying. Pam is realizing that even if she did pass the course, this isn't for her. But she's also embarrassed that she failed. But what she definitely does not want to do is spend 12 more weeks studying something she doesn't love. For me, in that moment, I just saw Pam stating her truth, and I always think that's so powerful.
事实是，潘发现她对平面设计根本没有热情。这大概就是我在电话里和吉姆拍那场戏时脑子里想的，当时潘在哭。潘意识到即使她通过了这门课程，这也并不适合她。但她也为自己不及格感到尴尬。而她绝对不想做的是再花12周去学习一件她并不热爱的事情。对当时的乐于此事的我来说，我只看到潘在诉说她的真相，我总是觉得这非常有力量。
Yeah. There is a very sweet deleted scene, you guys, with Jim and Pam. Pam's in the break room. And you know what? I'm titling it. What? Love in the break room. What is it?
对啊。你们知道的，有一个非常温馨的删减片段，是关于吉姆和潘的。潘在休息室里。你知道吗？我给它取了个名字。什么？休息室里的爱。是什么？
Pam is showing Jim her art assignment. She has this portfolio, and she's showing him the piece that she got an F on. Oh, I remember shooting this now. Yes. Yes. Oh, I remember it. It's really sweet. And as he goes through her art assignments in the back, tucked in the binder, is a sketch
潘正在向吉姆展示她的艺术作业。她拿着这个作品集，正向他展示她得F的那幅作品。哦，我现在记起拍这场戏了。是的。是的。哦，我记起来了。真的非常温馨。当他翻看她后面的艺术作业时，在文件夹的夹层里，是一本素描
pad. And he's like, what is this? And she said, oh, you know, it's just sketches of things I would see in New York. And when you look at them, Jenna, and I'll put it in stories, it's like people sitting at a cafe, things she might have seen on her walk, and they're really good. And this is such a wonderful moment. I wish it had stayed in. Sam, can you play the clip?
本。他问，这是什么？她说，哦，你知道的，这只是一些我在纽约看到的景物的素描。当你看着它们时，珍娜，我会把它发到快拍里，那就像是人们坐在咖啡馆里，她在散步时可能看到的景象，它们真的很好。这真的是一个绝妙的时刻。我真希望它能保留下来。萨姆，你能播放这段剪辑吗？
This is my project. Before we start, how did you fail? You're good at art. See? Yeah. I made a logo for a coffee company. Oh, that's nice. This is the one that got an A. The teacher handed it out, and this is mine.
这就是我的项目。在我们开始之前，你怎么会不及格？你擅长艺术。看？对啊。我为一家咖啡公司设计了一个标志。哦，真不错。这就是那个得A的作业。老师把它发下来了，而这是我的。
That's cool. I couldn't get it to print out right, so I got an F. I would have given you a D. That's only because we're sleeping with a professor. These are cool. What's this? That's my sketchbook. It's just, you know, stuff I saw in New York, people in the subway. Whoa.
挺酷的。我没能把它正确打印出来，所以我得了个F。我只会给你个D。那只是因为我们在和教授睡觉。这些很酷。这是什么？那是我的素描本。这只是，你知道的，我在纽约看到的东西，地铁里的人。哇。
This is great. So much different than your other work. Wow, Pam, that is awesome. Yeah? Yeah. Oh, I wish that had stayed in. It's a really sweet scene, and I feel like it just shows what Pam did get out of New York, and I really wish it had been in the episode.
这太棒了。和你的其他作品很不一样。哇，潘，这太棒了。是吗？对啊。哦，我真希望这段能保留下来。这是一场非常温馨的场景，我觉得它展现了潘从纽约真正收获的东西，我真的很希望它能留在正片里。
I agree, because I don't think Pam's art story is over yet. You know, she did not have the benefit of, I think, parents or role models who encouraged her to follow this piece of herself. And she only finally does now have that person in Jim. So she's going to have to take her art journey at the same time as her romantic journey. Well, I'm going to put that scene in stories, because it's really sweet. I loved it. I did, too.
我完全同意，因为我不认为潘的艺术故事就这样结束了。你知道的，她没有从父母或榜样那里得到鼓励她去追寻自我这一面的好处。而她现在终于在吉姆身上找到了这样一个人。所以她必须在她的艺术之旅的同时，继续她的浪漫之旅。好吧，我会把那个场景发到快拍里，因为真的很温馨。我爱极了。我也是。
Well, that kind of wraps up this episode. Yeah. Thank you to everyone who helped us make this episode. Brent Forrester, Randy Cordray, Wendy McClendon-Covey, and Rich Summer, thanks for coming on for an interview. It takes a village. It does, and thank you to you guys for sending in awesome questions, and Winnipeg Trivia. Yes.
好吧，这就差不多为这集画上句号了。对啊。感谢所有帮助我们制作这一集的人。布伦特·福雷斯特、兰迪·科德雷、温迪·麦克伦东-科维以及里奇·萨默，感谢你们接受采访。这需要整个村庄的努力。确实如此，也谢谢你们大家发来精彩的问题和温尼伯冷知识。是的。
Some last parting advice. According to Andy, Long Island ice teas are way stronger in Canada, so be careful the next time you order one of those, yes. All right, you guys. Well, that was business trip, and we will be seeing you next week. Yeah, see you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
一些最后的临别建议。根据安迪的说法，长岛冰茶在加拿大要烈得多，所以下次你点这种酒时要小心，是的。好了，伙计们。好吧，这就是《商务旅行》，我们下周见。对啊，下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾斯莉·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。想要免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。